bonjour à toutes et à tous il est 17h30
et nous pouvons commencer notre séance
donc en cette fin d'après-midi nous
avons le plaisir d'accueillir monsieur
Peppa Ndiaye ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie de votre
disponibilité pour cette routine
audition que nous avons souhaité centré
principalement sur deux sujets la mixité
sociale et scolaire d'une part et la
préparation de la rentrée scolaire
d'autre part donc s'agissant de la
mixité sociale et scolaire qui était
l'une des priorités de votre ministère
de séries de mesures ont été annoncées
au mois de mai il s'agit d'abord de
créer dans chaque académie une instance
associant collectivité parents d'élèves
et rectorat qui devra définir une
feuille de route pour réduire les
différents recrutement social entre
établissement de 20% d'ici 4 ans donc la
création de ces instances devait
intervenir avant l'été est-elle
aujourd'hui effective et quel levier
pourront-elles actionner
il s'agit également de mettre à
contribution les établissements privés
lesquels se sont engagés augmentés au
minimum de 50% en 5 ans le nombre
d'établissements proposant des
modulations tarifaires en fonction des
revenus des parents ainsi qu'à augmenter
le nombre d'élèves boursiers pouvez-vous
faire le point sur ces différentes
mesures leur calendrier et les résultats
attendus et par ailleurs et quand bien
même nous amorçons seulement la première
semaine des vacances scolaires la
préparation de la rentrée prochaine vous
occupe depuis un moment déjà et soulève
quelques questions à nouveau les
concours de recrutement des enseignants
du premier du second degré n'ont pas
permis de pouvoir tous les postes
ouverts avec plus de 15% de postes non
pourvu dans le second degré général et
technologique et plus de 25% pour
l'enseignement au lycée professionnel
s'agissant du premier degré vous avez
indiqué que tous les candidats sur liste
complémentaires seraient appelés quels
sont les autres mesures envisagées pour
garantir à chaque élève d'avoir un
enseignant dans chaque discipline à la
rentrée et pouvez-vous préciser de
quelle manière le recrutement des
enseignants à bac+3 pourrait contribuer
à remédier à la crise d'attractivité de
la profession et quel est le calendrier
envisagé donc après ces quelques propos
liminaires et questions monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je suis
très heureux d'être parmi vous quelques
jours après le début des vacances
scolaires et je vais revenir à votre
invitation sur la préparation de cette
rentrée avec des objectifs qui sont
clairs pour le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse instruire
les élèves et rehausser le niveau
général
assurer la présence d'un professeur dans
chaque classe et faire de telle sorte
que les élèves bénéficient de l'ensemble
des heures qui leur sont dues et enfin
accueillir en sécurité les élèves et les
personnels dans les établissements ont
été touchés par les violences
urbaines de la fin du mois de juin à ce
sujet si vous me permettez un mot sur la
séquence et me tiers qui a été très
violente dans l'ensemble du pays
notre responsabilité dans les mots et
dans les actes et grandes j'ai je l'ai
dit et je le redis à nouveau sans
prendre de cette manière au bâtiment
public mais aussi à des commerces
et
sans prendre aux écoles c'est c'est
inexcusable cela doit être condamné et
la justice passe mais nous devons aussi
nous poser question dans certains
territoires des phénomènes d'inégalités
de relégation mettent en péril la
réussite et l'avenir de nos jeunes le
taux de chômage a baissé dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville mais
il est encore très élevé deux fois et
demi plus élevé nous devons nous
attacher à résoudre cette question
d'accès à l'emploi qui est lié à des
questions de formation mais aussi à des
questions de discrimination
l'école peut beaucoup elle est un
vecteur d'émancipation mais elle ne peut
pas tout c'est pour ça aussi qu'il est
nécessaire de travailler sur la
responsabilité des parents leur
implication dans le parcours scolaire de
leur enfant les parents doivent soutenir
les professeurs dans leur rôle et c'est
aussi grâce aux parents que nous
resterons l'autorité des enseignants et
leur place dans la société
il faut
reconnaître les difficultés spécifiques
qui se posent dans certains territoires
combattre les inégalités à la racine
justement quelques il y a quelques jours
le président de la République présentait
lors d'un déplacement à Marseille les
mesures que nous avions élaborées pour
les quartiers prioritaires de la ville
l'accueil continue de 8h à 18h dans les
collèges la généralisation des cités
éducatives le développement de l'accueil
des enfants dans les toutes petites
sections des deux ans
dans ces perspectives nous avons élaboré
la feuille de route pour les prochains
mois la circulaire de rentrer il est
possible que vous l'ayez eu je pense
qu'elle vous a été envoyé très bien
a été envoyé au personnel de l'éducation
nationale la semaine dernière et cette
feuille de route mais en avant et met au
premier plan
deux outils qui vont contribuer à
changer les choses d'une part le pacte
enseignant qui va assurer une meilleure
continuité des enseignements avec le
renforcement du remplacement de courte
durée notamment mais aussi des missions
nouvelles assurées par les professeurs
volontaires plus de Français de
mathématiques en sixième des défis des
élèves mieux accompagnés avec la
généralisation de devoir faire en
sixième par exemple et puis le CNR
éducation plus de 18000 écoles et
établissements soient à peu près 30% de
l'ensemble ce sont inscrits dans cette
démarche de concertation et d'innovation
pédagogique qui est appuyée par un fond
qui a été abondé à hauteur de 150
millions d'euros pour l'année 2023
en fonction de ces outils des évolutions
majeures vont avoir lieu de l'école
primaire au lycée d'abord à l'école
primaire
l'acquisition des savoirs fondamentaux
sera encore renforcé avec le déploiement
des évaluations nationales en CM1
également en quatrième nous poursuivons
le dédoublement des classes de grandes
sections de masse de maternelle nous
serons à environ 85% en à la rentrée
2023 et à 100% à la rentrée 2024 le
déploiement de la nouvelle classe de 6e
j'en parlais un instant il y a un
instant avec le dispositif de warfait
l'heure de soutien approfondissement en
français et en mathématiques au lycée
général et technologique une heure et
demie de mathématiques introduite dans
le tronc commun pour que les élèves qui
ne suivent pas la spécialité
mathématique
puisse néanmoins avoir cet enseignement
de mathématiques qui est absolument
essent ielle et puis au lycée
professionnel la réforme qui se déploie
dès la rentrée avec des groupes à
effectifs réduits pour les savoirs
fondamentaux la gratification des
périodes de stage pour motiver les
élèves la création de bureau des
entreprises pour assurer une insertion
facilité dans les stages et dans
l'emploi
et un rapprochement entre le bassin
d'emplois en général et puis les lycées
professionnels
enfin l'organisation de la scolarité des
examens qui est évidemment là aussi un
point essentiel vous savez que cette
question de la reconquête du mois de
juin elle est très ancienne l'un de mes
collaborateurs me signalaient que déjà à
l'époque de Xavier Darko sans parler de
reconquérir le mois de juin
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas fait pour le
moins j'ai chargé un recteur honoraires
le recteur William Marois d'une mission
qui vise à reconfigurer le troisième
trimestre au collège et au lycée il est
clair que nous avons absolument comme
absolu priorité le fait que les
apprentissages puissent s'effectuer
jusqu'au dernier jour de l'année
scolaire
vous savez aussi qu'il y a une
problématique spécifique pour l'année de
terminale puisque nous avons et c'est ce
que j'avais dit d'ailleurs il y a un an
nous allons organiser le bac selon les
modalités prévues et nous regarderons ce
qu'il en est
la réforme du bac était très utile à la
manquer à la marque des bénéfices pour
les élèves néanmoins les modalités
d'organisation doivent être revues
puisque après la tenue des épreuves des
spécialités entre le vin et le 22 mars
et bien nous avons observé de manière
générale un désinvestissement des élèves
parfois plus de manière telle que des
semaines entières de cours ont été
perdus en lien avec la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur des décisions
seront annoncées dans les semaines à
venir pour que chacun puisse s'organiser
et pour faire de telle sorte que non que
l'on ne perde pas c'est semaine de
programme
un mot peut-être si vous le si vous me
permettez sur la revalorisation des
personnels avec
à partir là aussi du 1er septembre des
professeurs mieux revalorisés grâce aux
mesures de revalorisation annoncées au
printemps et que j'ai eu l'occasion de
présenter ici de par une revalorisation
socle d'une part et puis une
revalorisation liée à de nouvelles
missions d'autre part pour la
revalorisation socle c'est-à-dire entre
le premier et le 7e échelon des hausses
de rémunération qui vont de 7,8 à
11,2%. c'est moins pour les professeurs
plus expérimentés c'est compenser par
une eau un accès facilité à leur classe
et à la classe exceptionnelle pour les
professeurs très expérimentés
à quoi s'ajoute bien sûr le 1,5%
d'augmentation du point d'indice
présenté par le ministre de la Fonction
publique il y a quelques semaines
du côté des élèves la l'accueil des
élèves en situation de handicap va être
encore renforcée dans la foulée des
annonces et des réformes
issus du CNH du 26 avril dernier
réformes présentées par le Président de
la République et je serai heureux de
préciser un certain nombre de points si
vous le souhaitez de même que la
question de la santé mentale des élèves
qui est une question qui qui nous
préoccupe et je travaille là-dessus avec
le ministre de la Santé la question de
l'éducation à la sexualité j'ai eu
l'occasion d'ailleurs devant
le groupe des
de l'égalité de l'égalité femme homme de
présenter un certain nombre de points
liés à cela il y a deux semaines et puis
enfin la lutte contre les inégalités
sociales et scolaires madame la
Présidente à laquelle vous faisiez
allusion et là aussi j'aurais plaisir à
détailler un certain nombre de points ne
mention n'oublions pas la question de
l'école en ruralité et de ce que nous
avons annoncé à propos du plan ruralité
et d'une visibilité pour les élus locaux
à 3 ans à partir de la rentrée la hulute
contre le harcèlement fera aussi l'objet
d'une mobilisation à la rentrée comme
annoncé avec la première ministre
généralisation du programme phare au
lycée nous allons nommer un référent
rémunéré dans les collèges qui va
veiller à la bonne application du le
programme PHARE dont nous savons quand
il est bien appliqué qu'il est efficace
et puis bien sûr un lien avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur le ministère de
la Justice les référents dans les
parquets mais aussi dans les gendarmerie
et les commissariats de manière à ce que
d'éventuelles des pots de plainte soient
bien prises en compte et bien traités
c'est la loi ballanant qui nous le
permet depuis mars
2022 nous insistons aussi sur la
mobilisation des parents et c'est dans
ce sens que nous préparons des documents
pour la rentrée parce que si les parents
peuvent être des parents d'enfants
harcelés ils peuvent aussi être des
parents d'enfants harceleurs et donc il
faut aussi rappeler les parents à leur
mission de sécurité de santé et de
scolarisation des enfants aidé bien
entendu les parents qui pour X et Y
raison ont dû en des difficultés dans
leur vie quotidienne dans leurs horaires
de travail pour suivre leurs enfants
autre mission liées à l'espace
protecteur de l'école c'est le principe
de laïcité que nous devons faire
appliquer strictement auquel nous devons
faire adhérer les élèves transparence
ferme-t-il pédagogique ou publions
chaque mois les données nous allons une
continuation à aider les personnels et
les chefs d'établissement en matière de
formation à la laïcité de sang aux
alentours de 280 000 personnels formés
dont 8000 personnels de direction sur
les 14000 nous préparons aussi nouvelles
circulaires qui sera publiée à la
rentrée avec des exemples concrets de
situations et aussi un intérêt et marqué
dans la circulaire pour des formes
d'atteinte à laïcité qui ne relèvent pas
de la loi de 2004 mais qui sont
néanmoins très importantes contestation
pédagogique ou bien refus de participer
à certains à certains cours ce principe
là c'est principe là doivent être à la
fois traitées avec toute la fermeté
qu'il faut mais aussi sous l'angle
pédagogique c'est la mission de l'école
et j'ai saisi à cet effet le Conseil
supérieur des programmes à propos de la
réécriture des programmes de
l'enseignement moral et civique dont
j'ai annoncé récemment le doublement du
volume horaire de 18 à 36 heures pour
cet enseignement à partir de la rentrée
2024 pour un enseignement peut-être
dépoussiéré plus incarné qui permettent
de mieux transmettre les valeurs de la
République vous le voyez madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés nous sommes pleinement engagés
pour que après une année de travail et
de préparation la rentrée 2023 marque un
changement mesurable concret palpable
pour les élèves pour les professeurs et
pour les familles
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre pour ses propos liminaires et
maintenant nous allons passer aux
orateurs de groupe pour deux minutes par
par groupe et nous allons commencer avec
Cécile relac pour le comprenait sens
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre donc il y a un nom vous vous
teniez devant notre commission afin de
détailler votre plan d'action pour
l'éducation nationale un an plus tard
nous pouvons esquisser un premier bilan
qui confirme que l'éducation est bien
l'une des priorités de cette majorité la
revalorisation des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale la consolidation
des mathématiques et du français dans
les programmes scolaires de l'école
primaire au lycée le renforcement de la
pratique de l'écriture la réforme
complexe du lycée professionnel la
poursuite de la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire ou encore
l'affirmation d'un plan de renforcement
de la laïcité cependant nous avons
encore de nombreux défis à relever je
souhaiterais tout d'abord revenir sur la
revalorisation des salaires des métiers
de l'éducation très attendu monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous rappeler
comment sera octroyer la part
inconditionnelle de cette enveloppe de 3
milliards d'euros sur une année
confirme une réelle hausse des salaires
dès le mois de septembre prochain pour
l'ensemble des personnels enseignants
aussi pouvez-vous également nous
apporter des précisions sur la mise en
oeuvre des pactes enseignants dans nos
écoles collèges et lycées à la rentrée
prochaine je voudrais aussi évoquer
j'ose le dire la persistance d'une forme
de ségrégation scolaire sur nos
territoires en effet certains
établissements scolaires continuent de
concentrer des élèves appartenant à des
milieux socialement homogènes qu'ils
viennent des familles les plus
privilégiées ou au contraire de celles
qui rencontrent les plus grandes
difficultés or la mixité est un facteur
de réussite cet égard en mai dernier
vous avez présenté un plan en faveur de
la mixité à l'école pouvez-vous nous
préciser les principales actions prévues
par ce plan et nous faire un point sur
le calendrier de la mise en oeuvre de
ces mesures vous l'aurez compris
monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui ne je
ne vous interrogerai pas sur la
direction d'école ni les décrets
d'applications de la loi du 21 décembre
2021 qui sont attendus dans les
prochains jours pour enterrer
l'accélération de carrière des
directrices et des directeurs d'écoles
réécrire leur mission en adéquation avec
leurs fonctions si fondamentales pour
nos écloses mais pour ma troisième et
dernière question je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur le sujet des concours et
j'en profite pour adresser mes
félicitations au lauréat de la session
2023 monsieur le ministre je partage
votre volonté de modifier la place du
concours de recrutement et de
professionnaliser davantage de Master
Metz pouvez-vous nous donner des
indications sur la teneur des prochaines
évolutions relatives au recrutement et
la formation initiale des enseignants je
vous remercie merci madame la députée
pour le rassemblement national Roger
judo merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre vous connaissez sûrement la
comptine vive les vacances plus de
pénitence les cahiers au feu et les
maîtres au milieu je trouve que cette
comptine trouve un écho sinistre en
cette fin d'année scolaire avec les
émeutes qui ont détruit 243 écoles et
dont 10 totalement comme vous l'annoncez
vous-même c'est le ministre c'est
l'éducatif se délite après cinq ans de
hollandisme et 6 ans de macronisme
l'école est en plein naufrage je ne suis
pas le seul à le dire cela est
parfaitement répandu dans l'opinion
publique et dans les médias votre
politique monsieur le ministre s'inscrit
dans cette sinistre
prenons vos priorités les fondamentaux
vous affirmez que le primaire est votre
priorité et vous supprimez 1600 emplois
de professeurs des écoles sans
sourciller au collège vos priorités
sont-ils lisibles vous augmentez le MC
vous allez faire de l'éco formatage avec
nos élèves il y a une heure de français
en plus en fait c'est une demi-heure de
français en plus ça n'est pas une
réforme au lycée vous avez malgré tous
les avertissements qui vous sont
parvenus de la part du corps enseignant
et de notre part à nous
persister dans la mise en place du bac
blancaire et maintenant vous découvrez
pompier pyromane que non seulement le
mois de juin n'existe plus mais le
trimestre n'existe plus voilà et ça
c'est vraiment votre œuvre directement
non par contre vous êtes extrêmement
divers sur des sujets qui ne regardent
pas comme l'a dit tout à l'heure avec
une certaine vigueur je dois dire mon
collègue Gosselin du groupe LR
et moi ce que je souhaite c'est que vous
puissiez vous interroger sur ce que nous
disent les ébetiers voyez-vous c'est le
triomphe du communautarisme dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville c'est
l'échec de 40 ans de réseau d'éducation
prioritaire c'est l'échec de
l'assimilation qui est la première
mission de l'école et là-dessus vous ne
dites pas un mot donc je suis désolé
monsieur le ministre mais je voulais
conclure vous voyez vous avez offert
l'Odyssée je vais conclure avec Ulysse
mais en fait il y a même pas de naufrage
le naufrage est achevé je vous vois
plutôt en commandant en commandant du
Radeau de la Méduse je remercie
pour elle et finups Léo Walter
la base découverte entre autres seraient
prise en compte et bien non Brico
obligatoire BRIC optionnel les
enseignants ont l'impression de jouer
une version absurde des Lego ou aucune
pièce ne s'emboîtent et dont le but
n'est pas de construire mais de défaire
un jeu dangereux qui sème la discorde et
détruit les collectifs de travail et
voilà que la Cour des comptes propose de
désertiser l'éducation nationale de
casser le statut des enseignants et de
supprimer les concours le Conseil
supérieur des programmes de Blanquer lui
emboîte le pas assumant de disloquer le
cadre national du service public
d'éducation bref on file tout droit vers
l'inévitable privatisation de l'école
prenait par l'Institut Montaigne vers le
modèle hongrois de Victor Orban c'est ça
une école qui instruit émancipe et
protège selon le titre de votre
circulaire de rentrée je ne vous pose
pas vraiment la question monsieur le
ministre j'espère simplement avoir su
vous faire entendre la détresse
l'épuisement et la colère d'une école
que vous avez abandonnée et que votre
président n'en finit pas de pointer du
doigt et de mépriser
pour les républicains Alexandre portier
merci Madame la présente monsieur le
ministre au lendemain des émeutes de
nombreuses voix en souligné que la
réponse devrait être non seulement
sécuritaire mais aussi scolaire
seulement les pistes envisagées par le
gouvernement m'interpellent accueille
dans les établissements scolaires de 8
heures à 18h réduction des vacances
d'été maternelle des deux ans en somme
il s'agit d'arracher toujours plus
l'enfant au cadre familial or monsieur
le ministre comment ne pas voir que
c'est précisément d'ailleurs ces émeutes
le signe de l'échec de ce modèle là
est-ce que c'est quand on regarde ces
événements l'école qui a péché moi je ne
le crois pas
durant ces nuits qui aurait dû descendre
dans la rue pour ramener ses gamins à la
maison est-ce que c'est les enseignants
non ce sont bien les parents qui
auraient dû d'abord et derrière leurs
enfants l'école ne peut pas se situer
aux familles vous l'avez dit mais c'est
important de souligné
surtout pas or cela fait des décennies
que l'on charge l'école de toujours plus
de missions des décennies que l'on
dessaisi les familles de leur autorité
de leur rôle de leur légitimité et l'on
continue à deux jours monsieur le
ministre ne passe sans une annonce c'est
un feu d'artifice permanent dans lequel
plus personne ne se retrouve on mélange
tout on veut tenir l’école responsable
de tout et pour quel résultat dans cette
période de troubles et de tempête au
lieu de clarifier le rôle de l'école au
lieu diluer encore un peu plus chaque
jour la seule chose sur laquelle on
attend l'école c'est l'instruction et ça
elle ne le fait plus correctement si
j'apportant bien un sujet sur lequel il
devrait y avoir ici une forme d'une en
sacrée c'est de faire que nos enfants
réussissent
le niveau de nos enfants baisse tombe le
constate et le baisse d'autant plus que
celui de nous enseignants baisse encore
plus ce n'est pas une critique c'est
juste un fait un fait malheureux et au
lieu d'en faire la priorité absolue vous
faites de l'école le laboratoire
permanent de tous les mots de la société
si bien qu'on y parle de tout mais même
plus de transmission des savoirs comme
si les enseignants au fond étaient
devenus des assistantes sociales ou des
éducateurs de quartier et là il faut
maintenant on siffler la récréation il
faut arrêter la surenchère l'école ne
peut pas tout l'école ne doit pas tout
que chacun fasse sa part par en
compromis et ce principe c'est non
seulement à vous de le rappeler monsieur
le ministre mais surtout à vous de le
faire respecter que compte vous faire
pour cela je vous remercie merci pour le
groupe démocrate Estelle folest
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la France connaît un contexte
des plus difficiles après plusieurs
nuits d'émeutes qui ont abouti à des
destructions des incendies et des
pillages dans toute la France
ces émeutes sont le fait de jeunes
souffrant notamment d'une absence
flagrante de cadre et d'autorité le
président de la République l'a dit les
parents sont responsables de l'éducation
de leurs enfants bien entendu mais
l'école doit également jouer un rôle
central pour faire des citoyens et créer
ainsi les conditions de la cohésion
nationale
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
dans cette même salle il y a presque un
an jour pour jour le premier devoir
d'une république est de faire des
républicains selon la formule consacrée
de Ferdinand Buisson dont je rappelle
qu'il fut directeur de l'enseignement
primaire en France à la fin du 19e
la première ministre a annoncé mercredi
dernier la refonte de l'enseignement
moral et civique refonte dont vous avez
précisé monsieur le ministre qu'elle
comprend qu'elle comprendrait deux
volets d'une part le doublement du
volume horaire au collège et d'autre
part la révision des programmes du CP à
la Terminale nous ne pouvons que nous
féliciter de cette fonte que nous avons
également appelée de nos vœux il y a
quelques mois ici même il est en effet
fondamental que nos élèves se
réapproprient la grande Histoire de
France celle des guerres de religion de
la philosophie des Lumières de
l'avènement de la République et avec
elle de la laïcité qui arrive par
l'école 20 ans avant la loi de 1905 je
le souligne je n'oublie pas évidemment
la citoyenneté jumelle de la laïcité qui
est depuis bien trop longtemps la grande
oubliée
monsieur le ministre cette refonte de
l'UC ne devrait pas me semble-t-il être
mélangé avec tout autre discipline cela
aurait pour conséquence d'engendrer de
la confusion dans l'esprit des élèves
pouvez-vous nous dire comment
l'enseignement moral et civique en soi
peut constituer l'un des piliers d'une
refondation républicaine à laquelle
l'école doit prendre toute sa part je
vous remercie
merci pour les socialistes à parentés
présent
ez en faveur de meilleure mixité sociale
dans notre école que le gouvernement
pense suffisant pour régler un problème
de fond dans notre pays la ségrégation
sociale dans nos établissements
scolaires dans de trop nombreuses
communes communes pardon les élèves
favorisés et très favorisés sont
majoritairement et très majoritairement
entre eux et les élèves défavorisés et
très défavorisés sont ailleurs avec la
publication des indices de position
sociale que nous saluons ce problème est
largement posé il faut maintenant agir
pour améliorer sensiblement la mixité
sociale à l'école toutes les mesures que
vous proposez ne vont pas dans le
mauvais sens monsieur le ministre mais
pour le groupe socialiste elle ne nous
semble pas du tout assez ambitieuse ce
sont des mesures qui peuvent corriger à
la marge mais qui n'agissent pas
durablement pour une plus grande mixité
de plus je souhaiterais attirer votre
attention sur 12 autres points deux
points particuliers le premier point
c'est le problème de l'évitement
scolaire par le biais de l'enseignement
privé qui ne sera pas réglé par les
mesures que vous proposez il ne s'agit
pas de remettre en cause la liberté
scolaire mais de réfléchir à la part que
chacun doit prendre pour que la France
continue à faire nation pour nous ce loi
cela doit passer par des mesures fermes
par exemple la mise en place d'un
système d'abscitation financière de
bonus malus sur une partie de la
dotation de fonctionnement selon le
niveau de mixité via l'IPS pour les
établissements publics comme privé
le second point c'est une inquiétude
concernant les annonces du président à
Marseille et sa volonté d'ouvrir les
collèges REP et réplus de 8 heures à 18h
sur le fond je ne suis pas sûr que
passer 12 heures par jour à l'école
permettent d'aimer l'école par ailleurs
oui c'est vrai ça fait 10 heures par
ailleurs tu as raison dis OUI OUI de 8h
à 18h ça fait bien 10h par ailleurs le
président annonçait dans la même semaine
réformer les vacances afin je cite
d'alléger les semaines qui étaient
toujours trop fatiguant pour les élèves
madame la députée votre question parce
que là vous avez déjà largement débordé
je pose ma question tout de suite les
semaines ne peuvent être pas être trop
légères pour les élèves les plus pauvres
et trop fatigantes pour les autres
monsieur le ministre donc ma question
qui s'occupera de nos élèves de 8h à 18h
et quels seront les activités
pédagogiques
merci pour horizon et à parenté Agnès
Carrel
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie pour votre
exposé clair comme vous le savez je
présenterai demain devant cette même
commission les travaux de la mission des
informations de la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
sur le bilan et panorama d'éducation
prioritaire en France pour laquelle j'ai
été rapporteur je me réjouis que le
Président de la République et vous-même
mais il est devancé en ayant annoncé
certaines mesures qui vont pour
certaines dans le sens de préconisations
qui sont dans mon rapport je ne
détaillerai pas ces mesures puisqu'elles
sont exposées demain néanmoins j'en ai
pour certaines un petit peu voilà elles
vont un peu plus loin que les vôtres
mais je souhaiterais revenir sur une des
mesures annoncées à Marseille les
collèges seront progressivement ouvertes
de 8h à 18h dans les quartiers
d'éducation prioritaire a commencé par
Marseille pour lutter contre l'inégalité
scolaire dans vos quartiers dit monsieur
le Président vous aurez le collège qui
prendra les élèves en charge
pédagogiquement de 8 heures à 18h minima
à plus précisément a-t-il précisé
de toute façon au delà au-delà de 8
heures à 18h je pense que il nous reste
que l'internat c'est pas possible
autrement c'est accueil continue devrait
être expérimenté dès la rentrée
prochaine grâce à des heures
supplémentaires proposées aux élèves à
travers le dispositif devoirs fait mise
en place dans une partie des
établissements ou des enseignants
volontaires aide les élèves à faire
leurs devoirs avant de rentrer à la
maison ou encore en participant à des
activités sportives et culturelles si je
peux comprendre cette mesure comme un
moyen d'éviter que les collégiens soient
parfois livrés à eux-mêmes je ne peux
que vous vous interrogez sur les effets
d'une telle pratique le dispositif
devoir fait semble aller dans le bon
sens car il permet aux élèves
volontaires et souvent en difficulté
d'être accompagné dans leurs devoirs
mais l'extension du dispositif peut
avoir des effets négatifs
à l'aune des récents événements la
question la parentalité est revenue sur
le devant de la scène au moment où l'on
demande aux parents de jouer pleinement
leur rôle d'éducateur et de
etransmetteurs des principes et des
valeurs à leur enfant et c'est bien
normal une telle mesure semble renvoyer
un message contraire si le dispositif
devoir fait et c'est tant bien que mal
de garder un lien avec le collège en
informant les parents des avancées des
devoirs l'ouverture des collèges sur tel
créneau dont les détails ne sont pas
encore très clairs semblent des
responsabiliser les parents en rentrant
après 18h30 madame la député votre
question
quel temps reste-t-il aux parents pour
prendre pleinement la responsabilité le
message subliminal est-il laissé tomber
on s'occupe de tout merci madame la
députée je ne voudrais pas que les
suivants prennent exemple sur les deux
oratrices précédentes pour dépasser
voilà
je note à côté donc c'est pour ça donc
voilà c'est
j'ai une comptabilité donc rassurez-vous
et je suis très attentive à l'équilibre
entre les différents groupes sur le
volume de l'année donc pour les
écologistes Francesca mascini madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre l'école
Achour et ce n'est pas qu'une question
de température qui monte vous le savez
malgré tous les efforts qui seront faits
nous ne sommes pas prêts à faire face à
la déferlante que le réchauffement
climatique cause et va causer à l'école
voici la liste non exhaustive des effets
des canicules examen reportés heure
d'enseignement qui ne peuvent pas avoir
lieu difficulté ou impossibilité
d'accéder à des points d'eau élève et
personnel épuisé cours d'éducation
physique et sportive annulée gymnase
trop chaud la situation est encore plus
alarmante dans les territoires
d'outre-mer où nous risquons devant de
voir les élèves privés d'écoles sur
plusieurs semaines ou mois car les
mauvaises conditions du bâti et le
dérèglement climatique se font sentir
plus rapidement et de manière exacerbée
le budget insuffisant permettant la
rénovation de quelques écoles ainsi que
le manque de concertation et de porte
d'entrée unique pour les rénovations ne
peuvent à date répondre aux besoins
auxquels nous devons déjà faire face et
la proposition faite par le président de
réduire les vacances d'été apparaît dans
ce contexte ce grenu et irrationnel
rénover le bâti oui mais seulement si
cela s'accompagne de mesure visant à
titre d'exemple à repenser nos rythmes
scolaires pour réduire les vacances
intermédiaires et anticiper celles d'été
rénover les cours d'école pour qu'elle
puisse être utilisées pour des
apprentissages extérieurs et légitimer
l'école dehors c'est plus concret qui
identifier une salle fraîche au sein des
écoles et par ailleurs dans certaines il
n'y en a pas j'aimerais qu'on arrête de
proposer des mesurettes car l'école a
chaud les élèves transpirent alors
qu'ils ont soif d'apprendre le personnel
éducatif est à bout de souffle les
directions ont des sueurs froides la
médecine scolaire est à sec monsieur le
ministre il ne suffira pas de distribuer
des bouteilles en plastique pendant les
périodes d'examen pour adapter l'école
aux fortes chaleurs en attente de vous
des prises de position forte audibles et
conséquente monsieur le ministre j'ai
quitté l'école il y a un an et déjà à
l'époque c'était chaud mais maintenant
passez-moi l'expression ça craint
merci pour GDR Soumia brouhaha
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur musée je souhaite vous
interroger sur l'organisation du temps
scolaire et le calendrier des examens
qui pose question pour la première fois
le nouveau baccalauréat général
issu de la réforme de 2018 a pu se tenir
sans connaître les importantes
perturbations liées aux conséquences de
l'épidémie du covid-19 leur est donc au
bilan bilan particulièrement négatif et
inquiétant qui nécessitent une réaction
à la hauteur des enjeux la nouvelle
organisation chaotique qui résulte du
bac Blanquer ne profite ni au lycéen ni
aux enseignants pour qui le calendrier
de l'année scolaire est désormais
intenable les 6 premiers mois
s'apparente à une course contre la
montre pour les élèves qui comme les
enseignants qui doivent être prêts en
mars pour les épreuves de spécialité
dans le seul but d'inclure les résultats
dans les algorithmes de parcoursup à
cette pression s'ensuit à une troisième
trimestre de sens des avril les
dossiers parcoursup sont bouclés et les
candidats connaissent déjà 80% de leur
note les conséquences étaient
prévisibles et les en font part d'une
importante hausse de l'absentéisme les
deux seules épreuves organisées en juin
à savoir celles de philo et le grand
oral ont perdu de leur importance aux
yeux des élèves qui se démobilisent le
troisième trimestre est ainsi sacrifié
au profit des logiques de sélection le
baccalauré le calendrier du baccalauréat
à Blanquer les dictée par celui de
parcoursup face à cette aberration
pédagogique les principaux syndicats
enseignants comme les personnels de
direction demandent le report des
épreuves de spécialités du mois de juin
au mois de juin cette nouvelle formule
réussit l'exploit de faire l'unanimité
contre elle-même la réforme plonge dans
le désarroi la communauté du catif qui
ne pourra se satisfaire d'ajustement à
la marge au-delà du bilan est plutôt que
de reconnaître à demi mot qu'il y a eu
des échecs que proposez-vous monsieur le
ministre afin de remédier à ce non sens
pédagogique comment le gouvernement
visage-t-il d'organiser un baccalauréat
général qui permettent au lycéens de
travailler tout au long de l'année sans
subir la pression difficile provoquée
par les échéances
précipités je vous remercie dans les
temps dans les temps parfait pour le
groupe liote Béatrice Descamps merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre le premier sujet que je
souhaite aborder moi aussi concerne le
baccalauréat et l'organisation des
enseignements au lycée ça a été dit
c'était la première fois que le bac se
déroulait selon le calendrier mis en
œuvre par la réforme du précédent
quinquennat comme attendu les lycéens
ont souvent été démobilisés du fait des
épreuves de spécialité en mars et des
résultats de parcoursup à partir de
début à partir de début juin vous avez
estimé que l'organisation actuelle
nécessitait je cite une retouche vous
l'avez redit dans vos propos liminaires
mais pourriez-vous nous donner quelques
précisions aujourd'hui Monsieur le
Ministre vers quelle évolution vous
tendez-vous et comment comptez-vous les
mettre en place sans créer encore une
fois un fort niveau d'anxiété pour les
professeurs et les élèves j'en viens ma
seconde question qui concerne le métier
d'ense nous ne dirons jamais assez à
quel point le manque d'attractivité mine
le recrutement le recours aux
enseignants contractuels dans les
conditions actuelles n'est satisfaisants
ni pour les élèves ni pour les
enseignants qui se retrouvent parfois
livrés à eux-mêmes sans formation ni
accompagnement contrairement à ce qui a
pu être dit ces derniers jours ce n'est
pas tant le niveau master requis et le
concours qui sont un frein mais le fait
que cette forte exigence soit associée à
une faible rémunération et une
intensification du travail comment
comptez-vous inverser cette tendance je
rappelle que dans la promesse de
revalorisation de 10% en moyenne
figure-le les pactes enseignants qui
conditionnent une partie de la
revalorisation à la réalisation de
missions supplémentaires c'est forcément
décevant lorsque l'on sait du faible
niveau d'où nous partons troisième point
important vraiment à mes yeux
pourriez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
donner des précisions sur l'AC 8h 18h
annoncée par le président de la
République simplement qui accueille pour
quelles activités je vous remercie merci
madame la députée monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole pour cette première
série de questions ou d'affirmation et
je précise et je préviens tout de suite
mes collègues que nous avons plus de 25
inscrits pour la suite et ça vous donne
aussi une indication monsieur le
ministre que vous pourrez revenir sur
certains sujets si jamais vous aviez
encore voilà vous pouvez en fait j'en
appelle à la concision c'est bien c'est
bien comme cela que j'avais entendu
madame la Présidente je vous remercie et
je vous remercie mesdames et messieurs
les députés de cette première salle de
questions
un certain nombre d'entre elles se
recoupent et donc je vais regrouper moi
aussi mes réponses pour être aussi
synthétiques que possible
peut-être en commençant par
la question de des concours et des
professeurs puisque
nous avons aujourd'hui donc des données
à la fois pour le premier degré et pour
le second degré
avec une donc un mieux comme je j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire dans les
inscriptions mais aussi dans les
présents plus 28 % dans les admissibles
plus 17 % et dans les admis on est aux
alentours de plus 8%. c'est du côté des
professeurs des écoles on a quatre
académies toujours les mêmes au fond qui
ne pourvoient pas l'ensemble des postes
ouverts au concours de professeurs des
écoles c'est ce sont les académies de
Créteil Versailles Guyane et Mayotte
pour
Créteil on a quand même plus
13,1% de poste pourvu par rapport à
l'année dernière pour Versailles + 25 %
de poste pourvu en Guyane - 15% de
postes pourvu et à Mayotte moins 21% de
postes pourvu donc on pas une situation
qui se dégrade du côté de la Guyane et
de Mayotte qui s'améliore du côté de
Créteil et de Versailles mais qui reste
néanmoins critique la situation
s'améliore mais la part de poste non
pourvu demeure évidemment
importantes
c'est pour cela que nous avons
d'une part
organisée comme vous le savez un
concours interne exceptionnel qui a
permis de fidéliser des professeurs
contractuels et qui a donné d'ailleurs
de bons résultats dans les trois
académies où il était organisé Créteil
Versailles Guyane nous avons également
ouvert un troisième concours qui est une
voie d'avenir pour l'ensemble des
académies avec une hausse le
désinscription aussi en ce qui concerne
ce troisième concours et puis enfin
on a la le recours nous allons avoir
recours mais dans des proportions
moindres que l'année dernière à des
professeurs contractuels la situation
générale dans ces académies pour les
professeurs des écoles pour le premier
degré s'annonce donc meilleur que
l'année dernière nous avons une
poursuivons le recrutement de
professeurs contractuel mais nous sommes
dans une situation qui est moins tendue
que celle de l'année dernière même si
elle reste tendue dans les académies que
j'ai mentionnées dans le second degré
bien sûr il ne s'agit pas de difficultés
à l'échelle académique mais à l'échelle
des disciplines puisque on retrouve à la
fois une donnée positive c'est une
petite hausse des inscriptions des
admissibles et des admis mais des
disciplines qui restent des disciplines
en difficulté je pense en particulier
aux lettres classiques à l'allemand
ou mathématiques dans une au moins dans
une moindre mesure aux lettres modernes
discipline qui
elles aussi nécessiteront d'avoir
recours à des enseignants contractuels
nous étions sur une moyenne de 6 et demi
à 8 % l'année dernière pour le second
degré et de 1 et demi pour cent dans le
premier degré pour les enseignants
contractuels que nous fidélisons que
nous cdions aussi en partie et que nous
payons sur 12 mois désormais cette
question elle pose en filigrane celle
que vous avez que plusieurs d'entre vous
ont souligné
c'est celle des de l'attractivité du
métier à laquelle nous répondons madame
la députée
des camps à la fois par une hausse socle
pour tous les enseignants et notamment
pour les enseignants dans les premières
années de carrière on parle de hausse
qui sont qui sont toutes proches de 10%
ni aux alentours de 9,7% en moyenne pour
les 7 premiers échelons ça c'est
inconditionnel c'est pour tout le monde
à partir du 1er septembre et puis des
hausses liées à de nouvelles missions
pour celles et ceux qui le souhaitent et
donc en plus de la hausse dont je viens
de parler les nouvelles missions
permettront des hausses de rémunération
des hausses des rémunérations qui
peuvent donc en totalisant le socle et
le pacte dépasser 25% on est par exemple
aux alentours de 25% de hausse de
rémunération pour un professeur qui
s'engagerait dans des missions dans dans
une dans un pacte constitué de trois
missions valorisées chacune à hauteur de
1250 euros mais nous avons aussi insisté
sur le fait que la revalorisation du
métier d'enseignant ne passe pas
seulement par des hausses de salaire par
ailleurs parfaitement nécessaires je
mentionne aussi le 1 et demi pour cent
pour tous les fonctionnaires elle passe
aussi par des évolutions de carrière
elle passe aussi par la cuisson des
mutations elle passe aussi par la
revalorisation symbolique et morale du
métier d'enseignant à laquelle je suis
personnellement très attaché et donc on
a du mieux mais ça n'est pas suffisant
pour nous permettre de dire que la crise
de recrutement est derrière nous on a
une crise qui est à l'évidence une crise
structurelle d'où la proposition que
j'ai faite d'un recrutement à bac +3
nous sommes nous avons fait des
projections à la fois d'un point de vue
administratif et financier pour imaginer
ce que un recrutement à bac +3 pourrait
donner recrutement donc au niveau
licence avec deux ans de formation
rémunérées comme élève professeur on
peut penser à en cela à des aux
anciennes écoles normales si vous voulez
une instituteur ce qui a une vertu
sociale on recrute dans des couches
différentes à Bac +3 qu'a bac + 5 ça
permet aussi de recruter localement il
avoir ce qu'on pourrait appeler des
hussard noir de la République si vous
voulez du maintien siècle et puis on
garde l'enveloppe de la du Master
puisque les deux années d'élèves
professorat se concluent par l'obtention
d'un master donc on ne remet pas en
cause la mastérisation mais on dissocie
le l'obtention du Master du concours
concours à bac + 3 Master a bac + 5 ce
qui permet au passage de résoudre une
difficulté que tous les étudiants notent
pour l'année de M2 à la fois la
préparation du concours
l'écriture d'un mémoire de Master et
puis pour les étudiants en MEF les
stages à réaliser c'est une année
littéralement impossible pour nos
religion du Master MEF et donc c'est
vers cela que nous travaillons avec une
perspective qui est celle de 2025 le
temps de mettre en place les programmes
de concours et puis d'avoir un tuilage
entre les étudiants qui préparent déjà
le concours de Bac + 5 et puis ceux qui
prépareront le bac + 3 on aura
deux années de tuiles si vous voulez
mais cette perspective nous là nous la
considérons et nous là préparons
si
nous avons le feu vert il y a des
engagements évidemment financiers
importants de ce point de vue là je
voudrais maintenant
parler d'un sujet que vous avez
également abordé c'est celui de la
mixité et en effet madame la député
qu'éloha chie vous avez mentionné la
publication des IPS et nous l'avons
publié en data en Open Data comme on dit
c'est disponible sur le site du
ministère de l'éducation nationale de
façon complètement ouverte c'est un
point d'appui important mais j'ai déjà
aussi moduler la question des IPS en
remarquant que l'écart-type était très
important et que deux établissements
avec le même IPS pouvaient avoir des
situations sociales extrêmement
contrastées parce que le delta l'écart
pouvait peut être très large d'un côté
ou alors très très réduit on a donc des
profils d'établissement qui sont très
variables ou variées alors même que
l'IPS pourrait laisser penser qu'ils
sont à égalité en quelque sorte deux
établissements moyens à 105 peuvent
recouvrir des réalités extrêmement
variées et nous avons également j'ai eu
l'occasion de publier un plan qui
va se mettre en place à partir de la
rentrée de quelle manière eh bien cette
question elle ne peut être envisagée
sans les collectivités bien entendu ce
sont les collectivités qui sont
responsables de la sectorisation
donc le travail du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale c'est un travail
qui ne peut se faire qu'en partenariat
avec les collectivités en particulier
puisque ce point est le plus sensible
les conseils départementaux qui
s'occupent des collèges c'est au niveau
de la scolarisation des de la
sectorisation pardon des collèges que
les questions les plus aigus se posent
et donc cela va dépendre aussi de la
bonne volonté de l'engagement des
conseils départementaux et fort
heureusement Il en est un certain nombre
qui sont disposés à travailler avec nous
donc on n'a pas on va avoir une carte un
peu en peau de léopard si je puis dire
ça n'est pas nous qui depuis la rue de
Grenelle pouvons
accompagner une politique nationale nous
accompagnons et aidons bien entendu les
collectivités qui s'engagent dans cette
démarche particulièrement comme je
l'indiquais les conseils départementaux
et nous mettons à disposition des
rectorats qui vont qui discutent et qui
négocient d'ores et avec les conseils
départementaux un ensemble d'outils en
leur disant et bien choisissez les
outils qui vous semblent les plus
appropriés les réalités des territoires
sont très variées et on ne peut pas agir
dans un département comme le
Val-de-Marne de la même manière que dans
un département comme la Loire-Atlantique
par exemple il faut donc admettre la
variété des possibilités j'ai eu
l'occasion devant vous de déployer c'est
ces outils cela concerne aussi
l'enseignement privé sous contrat et
j'ai aussi mentionné l'accord que nous
avons signé avec le secrétariat général
à l'enseignement catholique avec lequel
nous entretenons des relations de
travail tout à fait fructueuse en
s'engageant dans une démarche qui est
une démarche
contractuelle une démarche
volontaire que nous appuyons bien
entendu puisque dans la dotation en
poste l'enseignement privé ce contrat
bénéficie évidemment de poste de
l'éducation nationale
il ne s'agit pas de dotation de
fonctionnement comme je crois que
c'était votre question madame la députée
kélouachi vous êtes là mais par le biais
des postes un enseigne un établissement
privé sous contrat qui fera un effort
particulier en ouvrant par exemple une
classe
Ulysse ou une classe SEGPA
pourra avoir sa dotation
améliorée par rapport à un établissement
qui ne fait pas cet effort d'ores et
déjà et c'est vrai depuis longtemps les
demandes des établissements privés sous
contrat sont supérieures au poste dont
nous disposons donc nous devons procéder
à des répartitions mais dans cet effort
de répartition nous pouvons inclure des
critères qui sont des critères du mixité
sociale et scolaire
j'en viens maintenant si vous me le
permettez à
disons à l'éducation prioritaire en
remarquant que nous sommes au travail
avec le ministère de la ville notamment
ville et logements sur une
réforme une refonte de la carte de
l'éducation prioritaire et j'ai eu
l'occasion par des échanges des apartés
que j'ai pu avoir avec vous ou lors de
déplacement de voir que cette carte a
vieilli avec des établissements qui
devraient entrer en éducation
prioritaire et qui ne le sont pas on est
beaucoup plus discret en général vous
êtes plus discret si je peux me
permettre cette remarque sur les
établissements scolaires qui ne
devraient plus être en éducation
prioritaire là j'en entends moins parler
par
une coïncidence certainement mais
oui en Seine-Saint-Denis c'est plus
il y a des petites marges qui peuvent se
discuter mais c'est vrai que c'est moins
c'est moins vrai et donc nous
travaillons c'est une question
extrêmement complexe qui nécessite de
prendre en compte un très grand nombre
de données et aussi le fait que cette
carte est difficile à bouger
reconnaissons-le parce que les les
avantages si j'ose dire en tout cas les
les éléments qui accompagnent
l'éducation prioritaire avec le
dédoublement
[Musique]
avec les primes aussi proposer aux
enseignants avec les temps de
concertation proposés aux enseignants
sont des éléments attractifs qui font
que sortir d'éducation prioritaire alors
même que l'établissement aurait toutes
les raisons de sortir
de d'éducation prioritaire suite à des
évolutions sociologiques que l'on peut
observer dans un certain nombre de
grandes villes ça c'est très compliqué
parce que c'est bien compréhensible les
familles les enseignants sont attachés à
ce qui a amélioré les choses pour
eux-mêmes et pour leur établissement
dans le cadre de l'état de l'éducation
prioritaire donc sortir d'éducation
prioritaire c'est compliqué entrer en
éducation prioritaire c'est beaucoup
plus simple je le je le conçois le
deuxième élément que je voudrais vous
donner sans sans vous sans dévoiler
parce que nous sommes en plein travail
et nous avons encore des mois de travail
en la matière c'est que globalement sur
les quelques 360 établissements et plus
on a une assez de stabilité des
établissements répuls les établissements
les plus défavorisés ceux d'aujourd'hui
étaient déjà défavorisés en lors de la
de la dernière révision qui date de 2015
mais qui a été fondée sur des données de
2011 il y a assez grande stabilité des
établissements réplus en revanche du
côté des établissements reps là il y a
pas mal de mouvements il y a des
mouvements il y a des établissements Reb
qui devraient sortir et beaucoup
d'établissements qui devraient entrer en
Rep et c'est là que les difficultés vont
être les plus grandes bien entendu
beaucoup plus que du côté
REP plus mais là encore nous sommes au
travail et j'aurais certainement
l'occasion de de vous rendre compte de
ce travail j'attends aussi le rapport
qui sera présenté peut-être la semaine
prochaine
madame la députée car elle est Monsieur
le Député judo à propos d'éducation
prioritaire rapport que je regarderai
avec toute l'attention possible à propos
des mesures annoncées par le Président
de la République où vous êtes nombreux à
m'avoir interrogé sur le 8-18 celui de
18 va être expérimenté dans
quelques dizaines une trentaine de cités
éducatives à la rentrée je m'empresse de
dire que celui de 18 pour les collèges
n'a rien d'obligatoire il s'agit pas de
rendre obligatoire la présence au
collège entre 8h et 18h mais d'offrir la
possibilité
aux familles et aux élèves qui le
souhaitent de pouvoir rester de pouvoir
venir au collège et de rester au collège
jusqu'à de 8h à 18h c'est donc une
extension des horaires d'ouverture et
d'accueil des élèves ça n'est pas une
obligation de présence de 8h à 18h c'est
cette c'est tout à fait clair avec cette
association entre scolaire et
périscolaire d'ailleurs quand on regarde
ce qui se passe dans les cités dans les
cités éducatifs particulièrement il y a
déjà de fait un des horaires qui sont
des horaires étendus dans un certain
nombre d'écoles et d'établissements donc
nous allons expérimenter à une échelle
je dirais moyenne à partir de la rentrée
les toutes petites sections je crois que
vous aussi monsieur le député portier et
puis c'était le cas
également de madame la députée peut-être
qu'il doit hachis je ne sais plus les
toutes petites sections vont être nous
savons alors là on a vraiment des
données très intéressantes sur les
toutes petites sections elles sont
extrêmement efficace elles sont
extrêmement efficaces là tous les ans
j'ai changé longuement avec des
enseignantes à beson là dessus il y a il
y a peu et elles sont elles m'ont
expliqué la différence entre des enfants
scolarisés à trois ans et des enfants
scolarisés à deux ans on voit la
différence dans l'accès au langage dans
la socialisation des enfants je dirais
aussi dans la socialisation des familles
bref c'est un ensemble extrêmement
positif c'est pour cela que nous allons
avancer dans la création de ces toutes
petites section en éducation prioritaire
pour
de manière à sur l'espace du du
quinquennat pouvoir
sinon généraliser en tout cas offrir un
un volant de toute petite section qui
soit favorable en accord aussi avec les
collectivités tout cela doit se faire en
bonne intelligence avec le secteur de la
petite enfance bien entendu il ne s'agit
pas de déshabiller l'un pour habiller
l'autre il s'agit de travailler ensemble
à partir d'un objectif qui est favorable
aux élèves je voudrais dire un mot sur
devoir fait aussi toujours dans cette
dans cette catégorie là de services aux
élèves de voir fait et généraliser pour
les classes de 6e disais à partir de la
rentrée devoir faire existent de manière
optionnelle en cinquième ça baisse
d'ailleurs le pourcentage d'élèves qui
s'y intéresse et de famille en quatrième
et ça remonte un peu en troisième avec
la perspective du brevet mais nous
généralisons en sixième devoir faire
mais j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que devoir après ça n'est pas fait
que pour les familles défavorisées avec
des environnements familiaux complexes
dans des familles ou avec des
environnements matériels je dirais et
des soutiens scolaires à la maison
lorsque l'on rentre à la maison les
enfants rentrent en fin d'après-midi
qu'il doit faire leurs devoirs enfin les
parents d'élèves ici le savent que c'est
pas il faut surveiller ces sources de
tension si entre les enfants et les
parents sur le travail fait ou pas fait
bref les les enjeux qui sont ceux aussi
des réseaux sociaux et des tentations à
la maison bref devoir faire c'est bon
pour tout le monde ça n'est pas bon que
pour des strates spécifiques de la
population et nous savons que c'est que
devoir fait c'est bien reçu le taux
actuellement eu d'environ 40% on est
entre 40 et 44% d'élèves de 6e qui sont
dans devoir faire on va passer à 100% à
partir de de la rentrée et c'est bon
pour les élèves tous les élèves et bon
pour leur famille à propos un mot sur
les dégradations
connus que nous avons connu il n'y a pas
eu 243 destructions et d'écoles et
d'établissements forte heureusement 243
dommages dont 63 plus importants et
parmi ces 63 12 plus importants dans les
243 il y a des choses comme des brides
vitres et des choses qui sont d'ailleurs
facilement réparables dans les 12 on a
des débuts des débuts d'incendie et des
incendies trois écoles ont été détruites
par un incendie et je salue au passage
évidemment l'action des forces de
l'ordre et des sapeurs-pompiers mais
aussi des professeurs des familles qui
se sont mobilisées pour
disons sauvegarder leurs et leurs
établissements lorsqu'il y avait un
départ de feu il y a eu là aussi une
mobilisation tout à fait impressionnante
donc nous avons du travail cet été pour
réparer
réparer les établissements et puis pour
les trois écoles qui ont été entièrement
détruites et bien nous devons proposer
et c'est le cas il y a encore des
réunions de avec des parents nous devons
proposer d'autres solutions avec par
exemple à La Verrière un relogement si
je puis dire une scolarisation dans des
établissements voisins malheureusement à
20 minutes à pied des établissements qui
ont été détruits donc il faut aussi
prévoir un système de navettes les
professeurs il y aura pas de classe
surchargés puisque les professeurs des
écoles détruites vont être eux aussi
relocalisés donc nous sommes en train
d'organiser tout cela pour la rentrée et
puis de procéder avec les collectivités
collectivités d'abord je devrais dire
aux réparations nécessaires pour que la
rentrée se passe dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
[Musique]
sur le baccalauréat vous vous avez
souligné et je l'ai dit moi-même la
difficulté du troisième trimestre et
donc il y a plusieurs hypothèses sur la
table dont l'hypothèse que vous avez
mentionné je crois que c'était madame la
députée bouroua à propos de du
déplacement des épreuves de spécialité
vers le mois de juin mais nous
envisageons plusieurs hypothèses à
l'heure actuelle ce qui est clair c'est
que le statut quo n'est pas possible
compte tenu des éléments que j'ai dit et
que vous avez par ailleurs
souligné
c'est
cela ne remet pas en cause parcoursup en
tant qu'outil mais c'est la question de
l'intégration des notes de spécialité
dans parcoursup Qui est qui qui pose
difficulté et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
que les épreuves de spécialité avaient
lieu au mois de mars c'était pour
qu'elle aide puisse être prise en compte
dans parcoursup il y a évidemment la
question ou la solution du contrôle
continu mais le contrôle continu soulève
un certain nombre de difficultés c'est à
dire la difficulté pour les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
d'évaluer les établissements les uns par
rapport aux autres un 13 dans le lycée x
est-ce que ça vaut un 13 dans le lycée y
c'est le problème du lycée du contrôle
continu qui peut se corriger par de
l'accumulation d'information sur les
lycées mais c'est quand même
c'est quand même une
équation complexe à apprendre en
considération et je me suis entretenu
déjà avec le comité de suivi du lycée
avec Monsieur Mathieu et ringard et puis
aussi avec bientôt avec le recteur
William Marois un mot peut-être j'abuse
de votre patience mais cette question
est importante et elle a été soulevée
par Madame la Députée Pasquini
à propos du réchauffement climatique
figurez-vous madame les duputés que nous
agissons et nous ne sommes pas les bras
ballants à ce sujet d'une part parce que
comme vous le savez le plan vert qui a
été annoncé par la première ministre et
qui est abondé à hauteur de 2 milliards
d'euros qui sera poursuivi dans les
années à venir ce plan vert et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le voir et à bien connu
des élus
des élus municipaux qui ont largement
recours partout je me déplace on me
parle d'un financement par le fond vert
et c'est évidemment une une très bonne
chose et j'ai remis moi-même avec le
ministre Christophe Béchu au ministère
de la transition écologique un certain
nombre de chèques si je puis dire à des
mers qui pour partie
envisager et envisage de rénover leur
école il y a le plan éduqué
je pourrais vous détailler ce dont il
s'agit et puis nous de notre côté nous
appuyons avec une cellule bâtisse
scolaire qui a été renforcée cette année
sur les questions thermiques mais aussi
sur les questions de débitmisation des
cours de végétalisation des cours c'est
un point extrêmement important on gagne
des degrés lorsqu'on enlève les couches
de bitume dans les cours de récréation
puis c'est bon aussi pour l'équilibre
fille garçon c'est bon à tous égards que
la végétalisation donc il y a énormément
de choses qui sont en jeu et nous tenons
compte bien sûr des difficultés de
financement des communes avec avec cela
et parallèlement à cela j'ai annoncé
nous avons annoncé un renforcement du
réseau des échos délégués de la
certification E3 des E3D des des
établissements pour l'instant on est à
quelque chose comme dit à 15% des écoles
établissements qui sont E3D il faut
progresser en la matière on en a oui on
en a dit on en a à peu près de mémoire
nous devons progresser nous devons
impliquer les élèves et puis nous devons
faire de telle sorte que l'enseignement
au développement durable lui aussi soit
valorisé un mot alors là vraiment sur la
réduction des vacances puisque c'est un
sujet aussi qui intéresse
monsieur le député Molac je vous vois
approuver
c'est donc un fait qui porte au fond
moins sur les grandes vacances les
grandes vacances sont concernés mais ce
sont aussi les petites vacances et
j'insiste régulièrement sur ce point
nous avons 36 semaines de cours 16
semaines de vacances 8 pendant l'été et
puis huit autres pendant le reste de
l'année ça signifie que par contraste
avec les pays européens les autres pays
européens nous avons des cours qui sont
très concentrés sur un faible nombre de
semaines et donc des journées lourdes et
des semaines lourdes cela tout le monde
peut s'accorder sur ce point avancer sur
cette question c'est c'est très
difficile
d'autres s'ils sont cassés les dents si
je puis dire tant les enjeux sont
importants c'est des enjeux en fait qui
concernent l'ensemble de la société
parce que au fond c'est l'ensemble de la
société qui est organisé en fonction des
vacances scolaires il y a des secteurs
économiques importants comme l'industrie
du tourisme par exemple et puis au sein
de l'éducation nationale il y a des
enjeux qui sont des enjeux d'horaires
pour les enseignants liés à leur statut
donc c'est un ensemble extrêmement
compliqué
qu'il faut pouvoir lancer et en même
temps sur lequel il faut pouvoir
échanger tranquillement sans
sans
hâter les choses de manière à pouvoir
arriver à des solutions aussi
consensuelles que possible c'est un
chantier de de long terme mais il me
semble positif pour nos élèves que de
pouvoir poser cette question et de
pouvoir avancer là-dessus si vous êtes
intéressé par les questions de vacances
apprenantes je pourrais vous expliquer
comment nous compensons en quelque sorte
cette longueur des vacances mais je
voulais d'ores et déjà mentionner ce
point voilà Mesdames madame la
Présidente ce que je voulais dire et si
j'ai oublié des choses je suis sûr que
j'ai oublié des choses
j'y reviendrai par le biais des
questions ou de la prochaine salle de
question tout à fait sachant qu'il y a
28 députés inscrits vous aurez le temps
d'y revenir donc d'ailleurs nous allons
procéder en deux temps donc une première
série de questions et une deuxième série
de questions donc on en prendra d'abord
14 et puis ensuite 14 puisque 14 + 14 ça
fait 28 et donc ce sera pile la moitié
donc sauf s'il y en a qui s'inscrivent
entre temps et je précise que son
prioritaire les membres de la commission
et que poseront en dernier les membres
les non membres de la commission vous
aurez vous pouvez tout à fait poser des
questions mais vous serez dans les sur
les sur la tout à la fin de la liste
donc nous allons commencer par gratter
la Melchior
c'est bon vas-y
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre qu'on rapporteur d'une mission
d'information relative à l'adaptation de
l'école aux enjeux climatiques je
souhaite vous interroger aujourd'hui sur
l'enseignement au développement durable
vous avez d'ores et déjà annoncé il y a
quelques jours 20 mesures pour la
transition écologique j'ai notamment
relevé votre décision d'un décret
d'intégrer les enjeux de la transition
écologique au cours de technologie et à
l'enseignement moral et civique
pouvez-vous nous dire si vous envisagez
de l'étendre à d'autres disciplines
comme la géographie par exemple et
pourquoi pas en faire un enseignement
spécifique pour exemple l'Italie depuis
2019 a intégré l'écologie comme matière
obligatoire à raison d'une heure par
semaine de la maternelle à la terminale
en outre je me satisfait de voir qu'une
évaluation portant sur l'acquisition des
compétences relatives à la transition
écologique sera mise en place pour les
classes de quatrième ou troisième
pouvez-vous nous dire de quelle manière
cette évaluation sera prise en compte
dans le parcours des élèves et pour
quelles raisons vous n'avez pas retenu
l'idée d'une autre évaluation durant le
lycée voire d'une nouvelle matière
optionnelle je vous remercie merci
madame la députée Bénédicte ozano
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre dans le Figaro du 7 juillet
un membre du gouvernement déclare
l'éducation nationale est un naufrage il
faut il faut pardon tout des étatsisé
monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce que votre
collègue entend par là moins d'État
est-ce donc moins de financement public
et donc une augmentation des frais de
scolarité l'article indique que le
statut de fonctionnaire pour les
enseignants pourrait être remises en
cause qu'il faudrait permettre donc aux
enseignants d'un exercer leur fonction
que pour une durée limitée en leur
garantissant des formations pour changer
de carrière s'il le souhaite
pensez-vous qu'il faut envisager
sérieusement ces questions ceci ne
serait-il pas incité à la précarisation
et à l'ubérisation du métier enfin
permettez-moi d'affirmer que ce recul de
l'État serait la porte ouverte à la
communautarisation signifiant le recul
de la France de ces valeurs et de s'a
souveraineté bref l'exact contraire de
ce pourquoi au rassemblement national
nous luttons je vous remercie merci
madame la députée j'encourage et
j'enjoins mes collègues à faire un tout
petit peu moins de bruit ou alors si
vous voulez avoir des conversations
privées le couloir vous attend Béatrice
Piron
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour votre présence ce
soir dans le contexte actuel quelques
jours après zemats importantes je
souhaite avant tout saluer la réactivité
du gouvernement ainsi que la
mobilisation générale de nos forces de
l'ordre pour contenir les récentes
émeutes urbaines les dégâts matériels
causés par ces événements qu'on sont
considérables et concernent
particulièrement nos bâtiments publics
dont certains écoles qui ont été
violemment invernalisés ces dernières
semaines dans les Yvelines mon
département au sein de la commune La
Verrière ce sont deux des trois écoles
municipales qui ont été incendiés
affectant directement plus de 200 élèves
et leurs familles pour cette commune
composée à 72% de logements sociaux le
coût élevé des réparations est estimé
après de 20 millions d'euros sans
compter les solutions transitoire
pendant la durée de rénovation de ces
bâtiments
monsieur le ministre quelles sont les
solutions que vous préconisez afin de
trouver des solutions donc à la fois à
court terme et à long terme qui tendent
à améliorer la mixité dans ces écoles
afin d'assurer la recolarisation dès la
rentrée prochaine de ces élèves
merci madame la députée
Rodrigo Arenas merci madame le Président
Monsieur le Ministre vous venez
d'envoyer une nouvelle circulaire
demandant aux écoles aux établissements
de produire des listes de fournitures
raisonnables pour la rentrée scolaire
mais je m'interroge car il suffirait de
leur demander d'appliquer tout
simplement les circulaires qui donnent
des listes de fournitures scolaires
individuelles c'est à vous qu'il
revienne les obliger et ne pas déroger à
vos propres listes car oui aujourd'hui
les familles n'en peuvent plus de
contribuer à ce qui devrait être gratuit
de payer pour que leurs enfants aient
assez instruction de qualité à savoir
les voyages et les sorties et les
transports de la cantine les fournitures
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que les
familles ont déjà dû couper
drastiquement dans leur dépenses
alimentaires et que dans le même temps
les collectivités territoriales
s'appauvrissent c'est à l'État d'assumer
pleinement son rôle et de débloquer les
budgets suffisants pour que la scolarité
de nos enfants soit véritablement et
totalement gratuite ce qui permettra non
seulement de mieux garantir la réussite
de toutes et tous mais aussi d'assurer
une meilleure mixité sociale dans nos
écoles alors je vous le demande monsieur
le ministre avez-vous prévu de
travailler sur la gratuité de
l'éducation en commençant par mettre en
oeuvre la proposition de votre collègue
Olivier Klein à savoir la gratuité des
fournitures à minima dans les quartiers
populaires je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député Francis Dubois
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre pénurie d'enseignants niveau en
baisse des élèves atteinte à la laïcité
harcèlement scolaire l'école de la
République va mal la rentrée 2023
s'annonce très difficile il est annoncé
plus de 3100 postes non pourvu malgré
les fermetures de classe à cela
s'ajoutent les non remplacements en cas
d'absence de professeur dans l'académie
de Limoges dont dépend ma
circonscription corrézienne les mers et
les corps intermédiaires m'ont fait part
de leur inquiétude sur les fermetures de
classe les postes n'ont pourvu et les
absences d'enseignants non remplacé
cette situation inacceptable a des
répercussions néfastes sur la qualité de
l'enseignement dispensé aux élèves leur
niveau scolaire empathie et les lacunes
s'accumulent tout au long de leur
parcours scolaire les courriers d’alerte
au rectorat n'obtiennent aucune réponse
pourtant nous aimerions avoir
connaissance des bidences sociaux de
l'Académie et des informations relatives
au non remplacement des enseignants sur
leur motif leur répartition géographique
temporel ces éléments permettrait
d'avoir une vision claire de la
situation et d'envisager la mise en
oeuvre de solutions durables monsieur le
ministre quelles sont vos propositions
pour remédier durablement à ces
problèmes sommes-nous les éternels
oubliés en milieu rural merci monsieur
le député Fabrice le vigoureux merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre une demande de précision et une
suggestion la demande de précision sur
le calendrier de l'éducation prioritaire
est-ce que certains collèges à la
rentrée 2024 sont susceptibles de
d'entrer en Rep ou réplique je pense
bien sûr à mon collège Dunois à Caen qui
a toutes les caractéristiques
sociologiques dont l'IPS pour
j'attends ça depuis des années donc je
voulais avoir des précisions de
calendrier deuxième une suggestion pour
conjuguer deux exigences très délicates
sur le calendrier du bac à la fois faire
entrer des notes objectives anonymisées
dans parcoursup les notes de spécialité
et en même temps faire que les élèves ne
lèvent pas le pied sur le troisième trim
estre est-ce qu'on peut pas envisager
d'avoir deux tiers du programme avec des
évaluations nationales par spécialité
qui donne lieu à parcoursup et puis
ensuite sur le troisième trimestre un
tiers sur le contrôle continu sur le
programme restant avec un ajustement des
coefficients merci beaucoup merci
monsieur le député Julien audoul
merci Madame présidente monsieur le
ministre vous évoquez régulièrement des
beaux et grands principes républicains
que vous bafouez par ailleurs dimanche 9
juillet sur radiologie vous avez
gravement et lamentablement attaquer les
journalistes de media français cnews et
Europe 1 en les qualifiant d'extrême
droite avec cette affirmation tout aussi
mensongère qu'un flamande vous avez
stigmatisé également les auditeurs et
téléspectateurs de ces chaînes votre
sortie illustre votre segarisme votre
mépris du pluralisme médiatique et de la
liberté de la presse ces valeurs qui
sont encore une fois charnellement
vissés à notre pacte républicain je vous
rappelle que vous êtes ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la République
française vous n'êtes pas le commissaire
du peuple de la pensée unique très
clairement monsieur le ministre la
question est très claire est-ce que vous
pouvez rester à votre poste et ce que
vous constatez présenter des excuses aux
médias CNN news et Europe 1 ou est-ce
que vous comptez démissionner
les chers collègues
je sais que certains
certains propos de part et d'autre de
cette assemblée peuvent et sont là pour
énerver l'un ou l'autre mais c'est pas
forcément non plus nécessaire de faire
un brouha parce que finalement on entend
pas et je pense que c'est un peu plus
compliqué ensuite pour pour les réponses
voilà
les députés ont la parole libre je le
rappelle ici
je sais alors vous allez me répondre que
le brouha aussi est libre à part que le
brouha c'est pas respectueux ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre je fais en sorte de
le faire je fais en sorte de faire
respecter le la sérénité dans cette
commission afin qu'en effet le
contrôle que nous devons exercer sur
l'exécutif puisse être fait dans les
meilleures conditions
c'est le but d'une je sais que voilà il
y en a un qui est en train de s'amuser
mais le but d'une commission notamment
parlementaire c'est aussi d'exercer le
contrôle sur l'exécutif et nous sommes
pleinement dans notre rôle quand nous le
faisons alors après que certains propos
plaisent ou ne plaisent pas je peux je
peux tout à fait l'entendre par contre
qu'à un moment on ne puisse plus
s'entendre dans la commission ça je ne
peux pas l'accepter Géraldine Bannier
monsieur le ministre vous avez annoncé
qu'un poids plus important pour être
accordé à l'orthographe lors des
épreuves du baccalauréat c'est
nécessairement une bonne idée que lui
accorder de l'importance après des
années nous avons été formés professeur
de français par une forme de défétisme
étrange au drôle de message de vous n'en
sauvez pas un or la maîtrise de la
langue
orthographe mais aussi maîtrise d'un
vocabulaire riche est un bagage très
utile lorsqu'il s'agit d'apprendre à
exprimer et maîtriser ses émotions mieux
vivre en société il suffit de comparer
des micro-trottoirs à quelques décennies
d'intervalles pour constater quelques
différences la lecture étant cela un
excellent vecteur toujours d'actualité
et jamais assez souvent mis en lumière
pouvez-vous revenir sur l'opération un
livre pour les vacances qui je crois
j'en suis même sûr fait la part belle
aux œuvres venues de l'antiquité alors
qu'on manque une nouvelle fois de
professeur de lettres classique avec 41
recrutement pour 134 postes cette année
aux capaces externes je réussis une
question concernant les professeurs
documentalistes comment peuvent-ils
prendre par opaque est-ce au travers des
travaux en groupe en information
documentation qu'il mette en place pour
les 6e ou pour des missions d'éducation
médias et à l'information pour
lesquelles ils sont dans première ligne
comme les collègues de technologie avec
un travail qui se poursuit dans toutes
les matières merci madame la députée on
voit que votre ancien métier vous
rattrape
Claudia roux
oui merci madame le Président de
Monsieur le Ministre la décentralisation
à mes yeux était une bonne chose pour
les collèges et les lycées en région
Bretagne on investit 840 millions dans
le mandat pour mettre nos lycée dans de
bonnes conditions de travail pour les
élèves pour les bien sûr et l'équipe
pédagogique mais aussi les agents j'ai
vu une émission très dernièrement à la
télé ou les lycées c'est en
Île-de-France c'était absolument
scandaleux de mettre des élèves dans des
situations de travail et des élèves et
des et l'équipe bien sûr enseignante
quels sont vos moyens justement pour
quelles sont vos pouvoirs pour les
régions pour les départements même pour
les collectivités pour entretenir
quelques fois tout simplement des locaux
les prochaines fermetures annoncées
prendront donc effet dans trois ans
pouvez-vous nous confirmer que les
instances de la concertation seront bien
créés dès l'année prochaine je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député
Philippe fait
position sur le sujet et quelle mesure
avez-vous mettre en place pour mieux
reconnaître leurs droits et améliorer
leur situation en tant que contractuel
essentiel à l'action publique merci
monsieur le député
Idir vous mérite merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je vous
ai questionné plusieurs fois sur les
mesures gouvernementales visant à
renforcer la mixité sociale dans nos
espaces scolaires vos réponses sont
malheureusement restées vagues alors
même que la ségrégation sociale
existante dans nos établissements
augmente et que vous affirmiez vous-même
que la France est le pays de l'OCDE ou
la ségrégation scolaire et la plus forte
nous savons que 35% de la ségrégation
sociale entre collèges en France est lié
au contournement de la carte scolaire si
elle concourt actuellement augmenter la
ségrégation scolaire elle peut aussi
être un levier de réduction ainsi
comment peut-on constater que parmi les
10% des secteurs scolaires qui ont le
taux de pauvreté le plus élevé il y en
ait un sur cinq qui bordent un secteur
auto de trois fois plus faible et que
c'est frontières entre secteur n'est pas
encore été révalué d'autre part pourquoi
certaines expérimentations notamment de
secteurs multicolores ne sont-elles pas
généralisées puisqu'elle semble
fonctionner dans la ville de Paris
merci monsieur le député Emmanuel
Antoine
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre en vue de la rentrée scolaire
de septembre 2023 le gouvernement a
prévu dans la loi de finances pour 2023
de supprimer 481 emplois d'enseignants
dans le second degré et ce après en
avoir déjà supprimé plus de 2200 au
cours des toutes dernières années les
suppressions de postes annoncées
interviennent et vous le savez dans un
contexte de croissance des effectifs
scolarisés dans le secondaire ces choix
de votre ministère m'interroge tant
qu'ils apparaissent préjudiciables à la
qualité des conditions d'enseignement
des postes d'enseignants vont ainsi être
supprimés dans certaines matières ce qui
contraindra leur collègue assurer un
nombre excessivement élevé d'heures
supplémentaires il sera en outre plus
difficile d'organiser des temps
d'enseignement en effectif allégés en
dépit des injonctions en ce sens la Cour
des comptes dans un rapport d'octobre
2020 a pointé du doigt le recours accru
aux heures supplémentaires dans la
fonction publique dont le coût est
d'ailleurs sous évalué alors monsieur le
ministre ne pouvait vous pas revenir sur
ses choix en matière de ressources
humaines dans l'enseignement secondaire
afin d'assurer la qualité des
enseignements à ce niveau merci madame
la députée Stéphane peu
oui merci madame la Présidente bon vous
le savez je sais que vous y êtes
sensible monsieur le ministre l'école
est la principale source d'espérance
sociale dans les quartiers populaires et
c'est là qu'elle doit et qu'elle est
attendue pour tenir sa promesse
d'égalité malheureusement si on croise
je le fais actuellement dans un rapport
parlementaire je fais sur la
Seine-Saint-Denis si on croise les
indices de position sociale et les
évaluations tout au long de la scolarité
on s'aperçoit non seulement que l'école
reproduit les inégalités sociales mais
pire elle les agrave et elle les creuse
et donc elle ne tient pas en cela sa
promesse alors concours principal
concours supplémentaire concours
exceptionnel encore une fois sur les
trois concours il y aura pas
suffisamment d'enseignants pour
l'académie de Créteil vous l'avez dit et
pour le département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis en particulier alors
j'ai deux questions d'une part est-ce
que vous dites vous admettez qu'on est
admissible avec une moyenne avec une
note de 4 sur 20 quand c'est 14 sur 20
dans les autres académies et si oui
parce que vous comptez faire pour que la
rentrée soit moins catastrophique enfin
juste pour terminer madame la Présidente
je voudrais apporter ici de manière tout
à fait officielle mon soutien au
ministre face aux attaques qui de mon
point de vue sont pas dépourvu de
racisme de la part de l'extrême droite
merci monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole pour
répondre
à ses 14 premières questions
merci mesdames et messieurs les députés
je vais peut-être
commencer par
la question de l'éducation au
développement durable que Madame la
député Melchior a posé en effet nous
allons à la fois du côté de l'EMC donc
ça fait partie de la refonte des
programmes de MC j'en ai je l'ai évoqué
également des programmes de technologie
de l'enseignement technologies en 5ème
quatrième troisième mais l'éducation de
développement durable on la trouve aussi
dans d'autres disciplines d'ores et déjà
par exemple dans les programmes
d'histoire la révolution industrielle
pour nommer que Kell n'est plus enseigné
comme on le faisait il y a 20 ans
uniquement du point de vue des
bouleversements économiques et sociaux
que l'Europe a connu surtout au 19e
siècle mais également du point de vue
des modifications
dans le rapport à la nature et dans les
effets sur la santé la pollution des
villes et autres données de ce genre
donc en fait on peut en fait inclure ces
questions relatives au climat et à la
nature dans
de manière transversale dans de très
nombreux de très nombreuses disciplines
je mentionne aussi le CNED qui a réalisé
le Beaba du climat donc c'est un vous
pouvez aller voir sur le site du CNED
c'est très bien réalisé donc on va s'en
servir et puis une forme de
certification en troisième que nous que
nous prévoyons il n'est pas prévu pour
l'instant d'aller du côté du lycée mais
je retiens votre votre proposition
madame la député aux anneaux vous avez
fait allusion à un article qui n'est pas
avec un personne cité je ne sais pas qui
mais je ne parlerai certainement pas de
naufrage en ce qui concerne l'éducation
nationale et pas non plus de
désattisation la fonction publique reste
absolument centrale dans l'éducation
nationale je rappelais les chiffres
précédemment 1,5 % d'agents contractuels
dans le premier degré six à 8% dans le
second degré la fonction publique reste
absolument centrale et j'y tiens à
absolument il ne s'agit pas de remettre
en cause il s'agit aussi de regarder
simplement dans les dans les jeunes
enseignants ceux qui aspirent à le
devenir
veulent aussi pouvoir changer sinon de
métier en tout cas avoir des évolutions
de carrière et donc ils veulent aussi
des portes de sortie si je puis dire au
bout de 10 15 ou 20 ans de métier
notamment dans d'autres métiers de la
fonction publique c'est déjà possible
mais plus de portes de sortie et puis
nous nous nous rendons compte aussi
d'une hausse des inscriptions bienvenue
par ailleurs des inscriptions de
candidats qui ont la quarantaine en
deuxième partie de carrière
professionnelle et donc il faut en tenir
compte c'est évidemment très bien
d'arriver avec son expérience
professionnelle d'ingénieur par exemple
quand on veut être professeur de
mathématiques mais valoriser au mieux
cette expérience professionnelle en
faisant de telle sorte c'est c'est aussi
quelque chose que nous avons annoncé que
trois années dans le privé valent comme
deux années dans le public pour le
reclassement de manière à ce que c'est
quarantenaires ne commencent pas tout en
bas de la grille salariale donc il faut
s'adapter mais ça n'est pas une remise
en cause de la fonction publique
les monsieur le député Arenas à propos
de de fournitures
nous avons donc nous publions une liste
de formes de fournitures disons comme
l'année dernière d'ailleurs raisonnable
c'est-à-dire calculer au plus juste pour
les familles vous savez aussi à quel
point j'ai je suis je soutiens et je
suis un ardent défenseur de l'allocation
de rentrée scolaire dont les montants
ont été annoncés hier ou aujourd'hui je
ne sais plus qui sera versé aux familles
à quelques 3 millions de familles à au
moment de la de la rentrée scolaire ça
c'est important vous faites allusion
aussi à des fournitures qui seraient
disons gratuite c'est le cas dans un
certain nombre de communes déjà qui ont
pris cette initiative Clichy-sous-Bois
par exemple la commune de mon collègue
Olivier Klein d'autres communes ont pris
des initiatives semblables la ville de
Marseille aussi a annoncé la queue que
les fournitures scolaires seraient
prises en charge avec différents
scénarios nous avons aussi calculé et
penser à différents scénarios les sujet
à l'échelle du pays sont sont très
importants mais nous soutenons les
initiatives qui sont prises par par les
communes
en la matière je soutiens aussi très
fortement j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
et je le répéterai à nouveau la
l'utilisation complète des fonds sociaux
les fonds sociaux sont à disposition des
chefs d'établissements et
malheureusement ils ne sont pas utilisés
complètement il faut que les chefs
d'établissement dépensent les fonds
sociaux pour acheter une paire de
chaussures un équipement sportif pour
aider les familles et les enfants qui
ont des difficultés donc nous appuyons
très fortement et nous demandons
fortement que les fonds sociaux puissent
être utilisés comme
comme il se doit à propos des postes non
pourvu je crois que c'était madame la
députée Dubois
à part dans le sud
toutes mes excuses là leur tourne alors
vous pardonnerez cette cette
erreur
qui ne qui ne tient pas du tout à votre
apparence physique mais c'est le nom
c'est le nom que j'ai mis sur alors nous
avons cette année
nous avons nous avions l'année dernière
4400 postes non pourvu donc il y a comme
je l'indiquais dans mon propos liminaire
une amélioration nous avons moins de
postes non pourvu cette année que
l'année dernière mais j'ai insisté sur
le fait que nous avons encore du chemin
à faire c'est vrai en milieu urbain
puisque les postes n'ont pourvu dans le
primaire c'est surtout dans des
académies urbaines à l'exception de la
Guyane et de Mayotte quand même que je
cite mais les deux très grosses
académies du pays en volume ces
Versailles et ses Créteil dans votre
académie on n'a pas de difficulté de
recrutement pour les professeurs des
écoles en revanche on a un sujet qui est
un sujet important et qui a été évoqué
par un ou une autre de vos collègues
c'est celui de la baisse des effectifs
scolaires ça nous allons perdre quelque
chose comme 70 mille élèves à la rentrée
ça va s'accentuer d'ailleurs puisque la
natalité baisse fortement à partir c'est
à partir de 2014 vraiment ça baisse et
donc là on est surtout dans des baisses
scolaires dans le primaire et puis ça va
se déplacer largement vers le collège et
puis dans quelques années vers le lycée
et je le note au passage vers
l'université et vers le marché du
travail dans un horizon de 10 à 15 ans
dans des marchés du travail qui sont
déjà des marchés tendus et donc les
choses ne vont pas s'éclaircir compte
tenu de la situation démographique de
notre pays mais ce que nous faisons
c'est nous nous assurons que partout le
taux d'encadrement le ratio entre nombre
de professeur et nombre d'élèves
s'améliorent je crois que vous êtes
député de la Haute Vienne Corrèze je
vais finir par y arriver mais j'étais
pas très loin député de la de la Corée
je n'ai pas en tête le taux
d'encadrement pour votre département
mais ce que nous faisons pour les
départements les plus ruraux c'est que
nous avons un taux d'encadrement qui est
un cadran meilleur que dans les
départements urbains et c'est normal et
c'est normal puisque la distance
l'éloignement fait que on a des petites
classes parfois des toutes petites
classes dans des dans des dans des zones
rurales ou au fin fond des montagnes si
j'ose dire j'ai visité une école dans le
cirque de mafat à la Réunion qui est
peut-être l'une des plus petites du pays
il faut des heures de marche pour y
arriver il y a pas de route carrossable
il y a 8 élèves de la petite section au
CM2 le rectorat nous reconstruisons
entièrement cette école
c'est des rotations d'hélicoptère c'est
pour huit enfants et cet enfant à la
rentrée et c'est très bien comme ça bien
entendu je pense que c'est il faut faire
des efforts particuliers ce que j'ai dit
aussi à propos et c'était d'une question
qui venait je crois du de Monsieur le
Député patriotus la question du rural je
me suis engagé en effet à donner une
visibilité dans les départements ruraux
pour que les collectivités puissent
avoir voir de quoi il retourne plutôt
que d'être un peu au pied du mur à
partir du mois de février et puis
pourquoi trois ans de visibilité parce
que les enfants qui naissent aujourd'hui
ils sont scolarisés dans trois ans tout
bêtement on a on a donc trois ans en
tenant compte aussi des mouvements des
déplacements et des déménagements mais
je ne me suis pas engagé à geler la
carte on a besoin de visibilité et
compte tenu de la baisse très très forte
des effectifs il va falloir procéder à
des ajustements de cartes scolaire mais
moi ce que on accepte plus et que l'on
puisse dire à un maire qui vient
éventuellement de faire rénover son
école ou autre pour la rentrée et
d'après et bien on va vous fermer les
mères ils ont besoin de visibilité ils
peuvent aussi comprendre que nous
ajustions la carte scolaire mais pas en
étant au pied du mur il faut de la
visibilité il faut aussi qu'on puisse
entendre amer qui nous parle de
l'arrivée de telle entreprise
ou autre qui va changer la physionomie
démographique de sa commune pas
forcément dans six mois mais l'année
prochaine pour qu'on ait un peu de
planification et que on puisse voir les
choses sans avoir le nez collé sur le
guidon voilà c'est ça et donc on a ces
commissions qui vont se mettre en place
en incluant aussi les préfectures qui
sont évidemment très importantes et
parties prenantes en la matière pour
discuter non pas de la prochaine carte
scolaire mais pour avoir de cette
visibilité pour planifier les choses je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
nécessaire et et
utile pour les pour nos écoles en milieu
rural
le un mot enfin plus que cela même à
propos de l'orthographe en effet
madame la députée Bannier nous avons un
sujet qui est celui de la maîtrise du
français écrit il faut le reconnaître et
l'admettre non seulement au niveau du
bac mais également dans les niveaux
inférieurs et donc
avancer nous avançons sur cette idée qui
est celle de d'introduire des critères
formels de maîtrise de la langue écrite
dans les épreuves du baccalauréat une
épreuve fort une copie formidable en
philosophie mais bourré de fautes
d'orthographe et écrite dans un français
approximatif je ne pense pas que l'on
puisse faire comme si la forme ne
comptait pas et vous savez comme moi que
la forme et le fond sont liés et donc il
faut pouvoir introduire des critères
formels par lesquels une copie ne
pourrait pas dépasser telle note si le
si le français est par trop déficient
mais cela a une condition c'est qu'il
faut aussi faire de telle sorte que nos
élèves puissent maîtriser les choses
correctement et donc ça c'est un effort
que nous ne faisons par exemple à partir
du cours moyen rapport de l'Inspection
générale
noter que court moyen
7% du temps hebdomadaire des élèves
étaient consacrés à l'écriture c'est
beaucoup trop peu il faut le reconnaître
les élèves souvent remplissent des
phrases à trous des photocopies avec des
phrases à trous et moi je suis un grand
partisan non seulement de la dictée et
la dictée c'est très important mais
l'écriture ne se résume pas à la dictée
je suis un grand partisan des rédactions
le mot fait un peu vieux jeu je le
reconnais mais écrire dans le temps
plusieurs pages et exercer son
imagination d'ailleurs son imagination
créative c'est excellent mais on peut
penser aussi au cahier d'écrivain au
compte-rendu de visite bref à tout un
éventail par lequel on fait écrire
écrire écrire écrire écrire écrire
écrire écrire nos élèves c'est très
important il ne s'agit pas de poser la
lecture à l'écriture les deux vont de
pair mais nous devons vraiment faire un
effort du côté de l'écriture c'est vrai
au cours moyen c'est vrai au collège et
faire de telle sorte que nos élèves
arrivent au baccalauréat avec une
maîtrise de la langue qui soit meilleure
qu'aujourd'hui je ne suis pas je ne peux
pas vous le dire autrement je ne peux
pas être satisfait de la maîtrise écrite
de nos élèves et on a des établissements
très sélectifs dans saignement supérieur
avec des enseignants qui nous disent que
le niveau
d'élèves par ailleurs excellent par le
niveau de langue de ses élèves n'est pas
satisfaisant et c'est dégradé sur ces 15
ou 20 dernières années donc il faut
pouvoir saisir le taureau par les cornes
si je puis me permettre et et placer la
question de la maîtrise de notre langue
notamment de la maîtrise écrite de notre
langue tant d'un point de vue
orthographique que syntaxique et d'une
manière générale grammaticale faire de
cette question une question centrale
avec une un effet sur la notation si
vous voulez voilà je pense que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel nous devons et
nous pouvons
commencer je me réjouis que cette le
l'accent mis sur les lettres classiques
et sur en l'occurrence les mythes
grecques vous vous plaisent ça ne ça ne
me surprend pas bien entendu
nous avons nous devons beaucoup à Homer
et il y a chez Homer de quoi raconter
des histoires de quoi de quoi lire des
histoires et de quoi se familiariser
également avec l'Antiquité puisque
l'Antiquité est au programme des élèves
de 6e et donc ça fait une ça fait en
quelque sorte une transition heureuse
vous avez
souligné aussi la question des
professeurs documentalistes qui peuvent
en effet être pacté je sais qu'il y a
des problèmes d'horaires parfois mais
bien entendu les professeurs
documentalistes peuvent tout à fait
prendre des missions proposées dans le
cadre du Pacte monsieur le député encore
deux ou trois choses une chose sur les
suppressions d'emplois je crois que là
c'était madame la députée Antoine cette
fois-ci je ne me trompe pas
lié à au secondaire alors dans le
secondaire on a une baisse des effectifs
nous avons une baisse des effectifs qui
est encore faible cette année
non on a une baisse des en fait alors
c'est juste l'essentiel le gros des
troupes manquantes c'est du côté du
primaire mais du côté du secondaire on
commence à enregistrer une baisse de des
effectifs du côté du collège pas encore
du côté du lycée et les chiffres que
j'avais c'était on a encore très faible
on est à moins de 2000 élèves dans le
secondaire à la rentrée 2023 donc c'est
évidemment une toute petite proportion
mais cette proportion va s'accroître
au fur au fur et à mesure un mot sur les
absh monsieur le député fait vous y avez
fait allusion du côté des avsh alors on
progresse un des enjeux c'est
l'amélioration de la situation des
avachage avec la CDI que nous devons au
parlementaire la civilisation en trois
ans au lieu de 6 avec la prime
d'éducation prioritaire qui est versée
aux aesh et aux AED depuis le 1er
janvier dernier avec l'augmentation
nette des rémunérations des absh de 10%
à partir de la rentrée de septembre
c'était aussi une proposition
parlementaire la dernière étape
importante
à court terme c'est celle des 35 heures
de passage de 24 à 35 heures et nous
avons deux voies pour cela celle de la
contractualisation avec des
collectivités de manière à ce que les
abassages est une seule fiche de paix et
que la collectivité nous rembourse du
temps périscolaire puisque comme vous le
savez le Conseil d'État nous a en juin
de ne pas rémunérer sur le temps
périscolaire la deuxième voie possible
c'est celle en effet de compléter le
service de par 11h
supplémentaire de 24 à 35 dans la vie
scolaire la vie scolaire ça n'est pas
fusionner les AED et les ESH surtout pas
c'est rapprocher les aesh qu'il le
souhaitent elles ne le souhaite pas
toutes mais celle qui le souhaitent de
la vie scolaire pour effectuer des
heures de vie scolaire qui peuvent être
liées à l'école inclusive parce que des
élèves en situation de handicap dans le
temps par exemple des récréations ou
autres ce sont des élèves qui peuvent
avoir besoin aussi de la présence d'aosh
donc nous voulons compléter sur une base
évidemment facultative le service des
aesh en le rapprochant mais certainement
pas en le fusionnant avec la vie
scolaire
sur les
un mot peut-être sur l'académie de
Créteil monsieur le député peut en effet
l'académie de Créteil et largement
concerné je l'ai dit par les difficultés
de recrutement de professeurs des écoles
c'est une quelque chose qui a plusieurs
années ça va un peu mieux comme je l'ai
dit pour 2023 par rapport à 2022 mais
ils nous ont recours comme les années
précédente à un volant d'enseignants
contractuel dont certains sont
d'ailleurs des enseignants expérimentés
seuls 13% des enseignants contractuels
n'enseignaient pas l'année précédente
donc 87% des enseignants contractuels
sont des enseignants qui ont une
expérience
d'enseignement parfois d'ailleurs tout à
fait conséquente donc c'est bien la je
ne nie pas les difficultés et ni le
niveau de recrutement d'admissibilité
c'est bien ça que nous avons si je puis
dire à saisir et c'est notamment en
pensant à l'académie de Créteil que je
propose un recrutement à bac +3 qui est
avantageux aussi du point de vue des
étudiants de votre département qui
peuvent financer des études à Bac +3
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à battre
plus 5 donc c'est un concours qui est
plus accessible ça permet de recruter
localement d'avoir ce que j'appelle des
hussards noirs et puis ensuite de payer
sur deux années des jeunes qui ensuite
auront un engagement bien entendu un
engagement de type engagement décennale
comme pour les élèves des élèves de des
ENS aujourd'hui ou autre pour que nous
rentrions dans nos frais si je vous dis
enfin que il y a un effet évidemment qui
soit un effet positif sur plusieurs
années je pense que ça c'est une réponse
très importante et et socialement juste
et qui permettrait de valoriser une une
jeunesse qui a envie de s'engager au
service au service des plus jeunes et
j'espère que nous allons pouvoir avancer
et je suis tout à fait disposé en parler
avec vous
je pardon un point sur l'éducation
prioritaire c'était vous monsieur le
député boomertile vous avez fait
allusion à la réforme d'Affelnet et au
secteur multilicé c'est une des vrais
possibilités la mais ça ça se fait aussi
là aussi c'est de la sectorisation et
donc ça se fait avec l'accord des
collectivités moi je ne peux pas du
point de vue du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale décider de la sectorisation ça
ça ne peut se faire qu'avec l'accord des
collectivités c'est pour ça que
j'insiste sur la nécessité de parler
avec des collectivités engagés dans le
domaine et puis les vantail aussi des
possibilités parce que en
Seine-Saint-Denis on n'avance pas tout à
fait de la même manière que dans une
ville comme comme Paris
le en matière de je retiens la
proposition de Monsieur le Député le
vigoureux à propos de de la de ce
dilemme de ce dilemme qui consiste à
objectiver tout en regagnant le temps
qui est le temps des programmes et le
temps d'enseignement ça fait partie des
des cartes et que nous étudions de
manière à pouvoir arriver à une
situation satisfaisante l'éducation
prioritaire on va sans doute commencer
par le Red plus parce que c'est le plus
stable je disais dans le temps de
manière à pouvoir avoir une première
fournée aurait plus pour la rentrée 2024
je disais que c'était beaucoup plus
compliqué du côté rept pour pour des
raisons
et puis
le coup des je crois que c'était vous
madame la députée Pierron à propos du
coup des coups de réparation
à La Verrière c'est cela
alors nous nous travaillons d'abord sur
l'organisation
sur avec un objectif prioritaire c'est
la scolarisation des enfants au cas de
septembre c'est que tous les enfants
soient scolarisés dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et là pas les
conditions idéales puisque certains
enfants devront faire des trajets plus
importants il y a des systèmes de
navette qui sont prévus que ce qui était
évidemment existant une école c'est 2 à
3 années pour construire donc ce ne sera
pas pour la rentrée 2023 ça va de soi ce
ne sera pas pour la rentrée 2024 ce sera
au mieux pour la rentrée 2025 en ce qui
concerne les écoles qui ont été
complètement détruites pour les autres
écoles y compris celles qui ont connu
des départs de feu je mentionnais
l'école de Bezons il y a il y a quelques
instants les réparations vont être
faites ce sont des réparations sans
doute coûteuses et la première ministre
a parlé d'un accompagnement de l'État
pour les communes concernées mais cela
ne remet pas en cause la la rentrée
scolaire pour les enfants concernés mais
nous devons avoir une attention
particulière pour les trois écoles qui
nécessitent une reconstruction complète
voilà madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre donc je vais
redonner la parole maintenant pour la
dernière salle de question Bertrand sort
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord vous exprimer mon
plein soutien dans votre action face aux
attaques innommables dont vous faites
malheureusement la victime dans un
entretien au Monde vous avez récemment
déclaré vouloir recruter des professeurs
des écoles à bac + 3 contre bac + 5
aujourd'hui tout en maintenant une
formation rénovée et rémunérée sur deux
ans après le concours pour ne pas
renoncer à la mastérisation des
professeurs en effet si la crise des
recrutements n'est pas aussi aiguë qu'en
2022 elle est toujours là il faut y
remédier et vous vous y e employer avec
énergie vous pensez faire entrer cette
réforme en vigueur à partir de 2025
celle-ci permettrait d'attirer davantage
de candidats avec des profils différents
ce qui aurait pour effet de diversifier
le corps enseignant c'est à mes yeux une
vraie nécessité
ayant il y a bien longtemps déjà
bénéficier d'une formation à l'école
normale d'instituteurs juste après le
bac là je le 18 ans je pense tout comme
vous que cette proposition va dans le
bon sens j'espère qu'elle permettra de
créer des vocations chez un plus grand
nombre de nos jeunes concitoyens car
être enseignant reste le plus beau
métier du monde dès lors monsieur le
ministre en complément des informations
que vous avez déjà fournies dans vos
propos liminaires pouvez-vous nous
évoquer les plus-values attendues par
cette possible décision je vous remercie
monsieur le député Lisette Pollet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre le 27 juin dernier vous avez
annoncé avoir saisi le Conseil supérieur
des programmes afin qu'il ait d'abord un
programme d'éducation à la sexualité
comme il en existe pour toutes les
matières mettez-vous donc ces cours ou
même niveau que les matières académiques
de vous nous préoccuper d'une prochaine
épreuve de brevet ou de bac aussi
l'éducation à la sexualité n'a pas lieu
d'être dans les classes du primaire
l'éducation au respect des autres et de
soi-même n'est pas de l'éducation
sexuelle et il est délétère de tout
mélanger laisser nos enfants se
construire tranquillement apprendre à
lire à écrire et à compter quand tu as
introduire des concepts comme l'identité
de genre dans les programmes scolaires
ce n'est pas de l'éducation sexuelle
c'est de l'idéologie le problème des
jeunes n'est donc pas pour vous
l'ignorance de la langue leur incapacité
à écrire mais bien l'éducation à la
sexualité ne vous ne devez vous pas
plutôt vous préoccuper de notre
classement pizza je vous remercie
merci Fabienne Colboc
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre depuis son lancement en janvier
2022 la part collective du Pass Culture
a permis à plus de 2 millions d'élèves
de participer à des actions d'éducation
artistique et culturelles dans le cadre
scolaire 50% de la cible nationale en a
bénéficié avec des actions dans tous les
départements pour près de 140 145 000
offres collectives proposées à titre
d'exemple en Indre-et-Loire depuis
janvier 2022 c'est près de 82% des
établissements scolaires cibles qui ont
réservé une offre assez dès la rentrée
de septembre 2023 les classes de 6e et
de 5e pourront aussi profiter du
dispositif par collective et c'est une
très bonne nouvelle cela représente
environ 1,6 millions d'élèves
supplémentaires monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire les retours que
vous avez sur les impacts du dispositif
actuel les freins qui ont été observés
et ou au contraire les impulsions qu'il
a offert aussi bien du côté des
établissements culturels que des élèves
je vous remercie merci Laurent espionné
[Musique]
Anne brunir
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur ministre pour vous répondre
détaillées à toutes nos questions vous
le savez la loi il a qui a permis de
nombreux avancées pour le métier de
directeur d'école en ce qui concerne la
reconnaissance la revalorisation la
simplification et le soutien dans cette
fonction directeur et directrice ont de
nombreuses responsabilités leur manque
souvent des moyens et du temps en ce qui
concerne le temps les temps de décharge
grâce à notre travail ont été augmentés
à la rentrée 2022 notamment pour les
écoles de 6 et 7 classes qui sont
passées de 25% à 33% de décharge et
surtout la décharge complète qui est
désormais acquise des 12 classes on se
classe élu de Lyon je suis inquiète pour
nos directeurs d'école car nous
subissons depuis deux ans de grandes de
très nombreuses fermetures de classe
c'est normal c'est lié à la démographie
moins 54 classes en 2022 - 40 classes en
septembre 2023
cette démographie scolaire en baisse il
faut l'accepter et c'est fermetures avec
néanmoins elles peuvent être très
impactantes pour nos directeurs car
certains peuvent perdre leurs déchets
total et passer à une demi décharge pour
une classe perdue aussi ma question est
la suivante serait-il possible d'être
vigilant pour ces directions s'il n'y a
pas de nouvelles baisse de seuil de
décharge je vous remercie merci madame
la députée Bruno bilda
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre si la baisse du niveau est née
depuis de très nombreuses années les
professeurs tirent régulièrement la
sonnette d'alarme notamment à l'issue
des épreuves du baccalauréat qui de leur
semblent pas toujours attester du même
niveau qu'il y a 40 ans époque où il
était encore une porte d'entrée viable
vers le monde du travail
des études mentionnent des disparités
entre élèves de filière technique et
professionnels et ceux issus de la
filière générale dans la maîtrise du
français notamment en grammaire et en
syntaxe votre ministère confirmait même
cette tendance puisqu'en 2021 il
estimait que 55,7% des élèves de 3e
avaient une maîtrise satisfaisante du
français contre 58%, 5 ans plus tôt la
baisse du volume d'or de français depuis
50 ans est mise en cause avec une perte
de près de 520 heures de français sur
l'ensemble du cursus primaire collège la
maîtrise la maîtrise de la langue étant
un facteur d'intégration et de
résorption des inégalités envisagez-vous
d'enfin rajouter des heures dans les
disciplines les plus élémentaires au
premier rang desquels la langue
nationale je vous remercie
merci Céline Calvez merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre en
préambule j'aimerais vous remercier pour
les efforts que vous avez pu apporter à
la recherche du meilleur mixité sociale
à l'école et vos annonces du 17 mai en
relève je vous la néanmoins vous amener
à nous répondre sur un autre sujet celui
de l'orientation des élèves dont son
programme en 2022 le président de la
République avait recommandé la mise en
place d'une de mes journées par semaine
consacrée à la découverte des métiers
pour les élèves des la classe de 5e au
sein de ma circonscription Clichy au
collège Van Gogh il a fait on a fait
l'état d'une expérimentation on a pu
échanger sur les différentes clés pour
mettre en place cette découverte des
métiers quid d'après vous de la place du
dialogue entre l'école et l'entreprise
de la place du dialogue entre l'État et
les régions qui peuvent avoir aussi
cette compétence et quelle est d'après
vous le rôle aussi à donner à ses
connecteurs que peuvent être des
associations telles que Entreprendre
pour apprendre ou encore job qui mettent
en lien ces différents mondes je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
Frédéric meunier
scolaire est un véritable fléau de
collégiens Lindsey et Lucas se sont
suicidés après avoir été victime de
harcèlement et pourtant ils étaient
scolarisés dans des établissements dotés
du programme fort phare pardon ne
devriez vous pas en déduire que votre
programme est bien peu efficace et
mettre en place une heure de
sensibilisation pour tous les collégiens
n'est-il pas un coup de com en réalité
le personnel de l'école féminine de ne
pas voir où les enseignants disent que
ce n'est pas de leur responsabilité
malheureusement peu nombreux sont encore
les établissements qui agissent
véritablement pour la protection de
leurs élèves deuxième question je
voulais aborder la question de
l'instruction en famille messieurs
Macron et Darmanin s'accordent pour dire
que l'État n'a pas à se substituer aux
parents et c'est donc aux parents
d'éduquer leur enfant leur est donc bien
choisi pour vous demander pourquoi avoir
supprimé le droit et même le devoir des
parents de choisir l'instruction en
famille qui correspond le mieux à leur
enfant ne croyez-vous pas qu'il est
urgent de rendre aux parents le droit de
faire leur travail de parents en
revenant au régime déclaratif de
l'instruction en famille je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
Christophe Marion
c'est bon
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre avant de parler de rentrée
scolaire je souhaiterais évoquer les
vacances scolaires vous étiez hier à
Avignon pour saluer les élèves de
l'école Louis gros qui bénéficie du
dispositif des vacances apprenantes
étendue à 27 établissements du Vaucluse
je crois que nous sommes tous d'accord
ici pour dire la nécessité absolue
d'accompagner les élèves les plus
fragiles durant les longues périodes de
congés afin de ne pas leur faire perdre
le bénéfice des mesures mises en place
par ailleurs tout au long de l'année je
pense ici notamment au dédoulement des
classes de cpce1 en repérer plus par
exemple ma question porte sur un autre
dispositif les colonies apprenantes
initiée avant l'été 2020 pour répondre
aux conséquences du confinement sur les
apprentissages des élèves elles ont
rencontré un réel succès et se
reconduites chaque année depuis 230
000 élèves ont été ainsi accompagnés
grâce à un engagement de votre ministère
qui s'est élevé à 180000 euros quel
bilan portez-vous de ces
expérimentations et surtout
envisagez-vous d'attribuer une ligne
budgétaire claire et définie au col
onies apprenantes alors même que les
financements sont reconduits chaque
année après évaluation sans donner
véritable visibilité aux associations
partenaires quant à quant à l'avenir de
cette opération merci monsieur le député
Marie-Pierre rexin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre si la vie affective et sexuelle
peut-être source de joie et
d'épanouissement elle peut être aussi à
l'origine d'inégalité entre les femmes
et les hommes et faire l'objet de
violence physique ou psychologiques y
compris d'ailleurs dans la sphère
familiale rappelons que 51% des
violences sexuelles sont subies avant
l'âge de 11 ans et que 44% d'entre elles
ont lieu dans la sphère familiale les
stéréotypes et les billets sexistes
préniant dans notre société sont
évidemment source de nombreuses ruptures
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
depuis 2001 la loi impose trois séances
d'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle merci monsieur le ministre pour
votre engagement à vouloir enfin faire
appliquer la loi pouvez-vous nous
expliquer les la mise en oeuvre de ces
de ces séances et enfin je terminerai
par vous rappeler notre notre soutien
face aux attaques absolument
intolérables que vous traversez
merci madame la députée Isabelle Périgot
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je souhaite vraiment y revenir
les résultats successifs des enquêtes
PISA montre que la France se situe en
dessous de la moyenne des pays
développés notamment en mathématiques le
résultat de l'étude internationale
Pierce réalisée dans 50 pays entre 2021
et 2022 et publié le 16 mai dernier
montre de son côté que la France est à
la traîne des pays développés concernant
cette fois la lecture vous l'avez
reconnu tout à l'heure le retard dans
les apprentissages de la lecture pèsent
très lourd sur les écoliers les
favorisés avec la lecture nous le savons
on développe des compétences
réutilisables dans tous les autres
enseignements c'est donc avec étonnement
quand même que nous avons appris il y a
quelques semaines cette volonté de
mettre en place les cours d'éducation à
la sexualité ou encore le 20 juin
dernier avec l'annonce de notre première
ministre de la mise en place du
savoir-vair évalué à la fin des collèges
la priorité ne devrait-elle pas
d'améliorer le niveau nos enfants sur
les savoirs fondamentaux que sont la
lecture et les mathématiques plutôt que
de rajouter encore de nouveaux
enseignements alors ma question elle est
simple monsieur le ministre même si vous
l'avez succinctement évoqué tout à
l'heure que comptez-vous mettre en place
pour précisément renforcer
l'enseignement de nos savoirs
fondamentaux je vous remercie merci
madame la députée Annie genvar
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre nos travaux en commission
surtout si là pour évoquer des sujets un
peu spécifiques je voudrais vous
soumettre une question concernant
l'enseignement technologique j'ai été
alerté par un professeur du lycée
technologique victor Bérard à Morez qui
forme des élèves opticiens et lunetier
et qui s'alarme du fait qu'il perdent
beaucoup d'élèves concurrencés en cela
par les CFA qui se multiplient
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs public ou privé
et
d'une sorte de concurrence mais après
tout la concurrence n'est pas toujours
mauvaise elle peut être source de
progrès
or l'espèce ce professeur qui est aussi
un examinateur ou
constate des niveaux très faibles
parfois
des élèves qui suivent l'enseignement
dans ces CFA certains sont d'excellents
CFA et je ne voudrais surtout pas vous
savez que au républicains nous sommes
très attachés à la formation et à
l'apprentissage mais en l'espèce est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose de
particulier à nous dire sur cette
concurrence entre ces établissements
merci madame la députée Farida Amrani
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans ma circonscription déjà la
rentrée scolaire de 2022 pas moins de
1000 élèves se sont retrouvés sans
affectation pour leur rentrée au lycée
ce phénomène se répète à nouveau pour la
rentrée de 2023 monsieur le ministre
cette situation déjà connue par vos
services de l'éducation nationale
auraient dû être anticipé et donc éviter
mais il n'en est rien les centaines
d'élèves concernés se trouvent ainsi
privés de leurs droits à l'éducation
alors que chaque enfant devrait pouvoir
avoir droit à une orientation choisie et
non subie oriente orientation choisie
tant du point de vue du type de la
filière que de la proximité de la à leur
domicile monsieur le ministre
entendez-vous vraiment l'urgence de la
situation et seriez-vous en mesure de
garantir une affectation à chaque
collégienne et collégiale de ma
circonscription sans leur demander un
redoublement alors qu'elle et qu'ils
avaient leur passage en au lycée et un
passage bien mérité je vous remercie
merci Paul Molac
merci
voilà c'est bon pour le micro
merci de la présidente donc si j'ai bien
compris maintenant il y aura donc un
concours à l'issue de la licence avec
des professeurs qui deviendront
finalement professeur stagiaire comme ça
se faisait autrefois donc ce qui me
semble effectivement être une ressource
pour pouvoir avoir un peu plus de
personnes je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose
vous avez aussi parlé de tâches
supplémentaires qui seraient donné aux
enseignants est-ce que selon vos
remontées est-ce que ça parce que j'ai
eu des avis assez divergents sur le
terrain ça c'était le ma deuxième
question et ma troisième question
concerne et évidemment les langues
régionales vous en douter très bien en
particulier l'article qui consiste à ce
que dans le cadre de convention qui sont
signés avec les collectivités locales il
y ait une proposition généralisée
d'enseignement des langues régionales
donc est-ce que votre ministère suit
cela
je sais que oui et les difficultés qu'on
peut voir et donc je voulais avoir votre
sentiment là dessus merci monsieur le
député Rachel kéké
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'attire votre attention sur la
rentrée scolaire prochain je souhaite
vous alerter sur la situation très
préoccupante des conditions d'études de
nos enfants en maternelle les parents
d'élèves de l'école de la Roseraie à là
il est rose se sont mobilisés depuis le
mois de février contre la fermeture
d'une classe et continue de la faire
pour plus dans Ush en élémentaire les
parents d'élèves de l'école du centre de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses se mobilisent eux aussi
pour plus de Ush au collège au collège
Francine froment à Fresnes les parents
et professeurs se sont mobilisés le
mercredi 21 juin
derrière
dernière devant le rectorat pour
demander le remplacement pérenne du
principal à qui connaît quatre
directeurs en 4 ans le passage en Rep et
l'ouverture d'une classe supplémentaire
au lycée Mistral à Fresnes les
représentants du personnel sont en
attente depuis le Samedi 3 juin pour une
audience auprès du recteur
nous manquons de tout à tous les niveaux
de la maternelle au lycée nous manquons
de moyens nous manquons de professeurs
nous manquons de classe nous manquons
d'ailleurs sache alors Monsieur le
Ministre comment est-il possible que le
statut dahuète sache ne soit pas
revaloriser madame la députée dans la
commission c'est une minute
pas les usages de notre commission c'est
pour ça que je me permets de vous le
rappeler mais au bout de 30 secondes de
déplacement je suis obligé de vous
couper le micro et donc et de donner la
parole à Fabien d'y Filippo
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre ma question
concerne les 30 minutes d'activité
physique par par jour et devait être
généralisé à la rentrée dernière on voit
bien que la généralisation est pas et
pas effective dans l'ensemble des
classes pour cause et bien les
professeurs ne sont pas tous formés à
ces activités non pas tous aussi une
formation nécessaire pour pour les
mettre en oeuvre de la meilleure des
manières ne serait-il pas plus judicieux
de regrouper ces 30 minutes qui ont lieu
sur 4 jours plutôt sur deux temps d'une
heure en faisant intervenir des des
éducateurs diplômés des associations
sportives pour les ouvrir sur une
pratique sportive réelle parce que la
réalité la réalité c'est que si vous
voulez donner une base et une culture
physique à ses enfants là ça ne passe
pas forcément par l'école ça doit passer
par les clubs où il y a des gens
passionnés des éducateurs diplômés et où
on peut inscrire une pratique et une
progression dans la durée
merci monsieur le député mais j'aurais
envie de vous répondre peut-être je
m'avance un peu mais pour ces parents
antinomique que de faire 30 minutes
d'éducation physique un jour et de faire
en plus de l'éducation physique et
sportive
non non mais je dis ça parce que je on a
vu quand même les bienfaits des 30
minutes physiques pour lutter contre la
sédentarité comme c'est un sujet qui me
tient à coeur je me suis permise de
répondre mais monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole maintenant merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés
une salle va encore de questions en
commençant peut-être par réitérer mon
mon intérêt ma volonté pour le bac+3
c'était vous monsieur le député sort et
les plus-values évidentes du point de
vue du recrutement je dirais du point de
vue de aussi de l'égalité des chances
l'accès à un métier qui a historiquement
était un métier d'ascension sociale les
enfants d'instituteurs les enfants de
paysans étaient devenaient instituteur
et parfois plus je pense aux présidents
Pompidou qui était lui-même fils
d'instituteur et petit-fils de paysans
et on pourrait trouver de très nombreux
exemples similaires parfois dans vos
propres familles peut-être
donc on a ça cet élément tout à fait
important également une formation que
nous pouvons travailler de manière à ce
qu'elle soit aussi efficace que possible
c'est deux années rémunérées avec
des stages avec tout un travail pour
faire et avoir des professeurs des
écoles qui soient opérationnelles et qui
puisse rendre les meilleurs services
possibles donc je crois que à tous
égards c'est c'est positif
il y a eu quelques questions sur
l'éducation artistique et pardon
excusez-moi l'éducation est la sexualité
y compris de vous madame la député
Pollet je crois pour remarquer tout
simplement que c'est la loi la loi du 4
juillet 2001 nous oblige à trois séances
d'éducation de la sexualité du CPA la
terminale et donc nous devons respecter
la loi vous en tant que vous opposer
pour critiquer la loop ou il a changé si
vous le souhaitez mais la première chose
à faire c'est de respecter la loi or on
a amélioré les choses puisque j'ai fait
faire un sondage flash il y a très peu
de temps qui a qui nous donne quelque
chose comme
36,5 % 37 % de
classe 37,8 par 8% par an pardon des
élèves qui en bénéficié d'au moins une
séance au cours de l'année l'année
dernière on était à
17,1%. c'est donc une amélioration mais
on a encore du chemin à couvrir d'où la
proposition d'où le fait que j'ai saisi
le Conseil supérieur des programmes
savez-vous que opposé
ces enseignements au fondamentaux c'est
à mon avis une perspective à courte vue
parce que dans les pays qui ont les
meilleurs résultats scolaires dans les
classements internationaux que ce soit
pearls
ou pizza et bien on constate que les
élèves ils ont de l'enseignement à la
sexualité ils ont de l'enseignement au
développement durable et donc c'est pas
comme une perspective uniquement
quantitative de robinet d'eau et de
volume horaire on a des questions qui
sont aussi des questions de pédagogie le
renforcement des savoirs fondamentaux et
auxquels nous je suis particulièrement
attaché j'ai mentionné leur ennemi de
mathématiques j'ai mentionné l'heure de
français et de mathématiques en 6e en
plus j'ai mentionné l'accent mi sur les
travaux d'écriture à l'école élémentaire
que cet accent mis sur les savoirs
fondamentaux il est tout à fait possible
de le concilier avec d'autres
enseignements qui sont nécessaires
l'enseignement à la sexualité on sait
que c'est bon pour les relations entre
les filles et les garçons ça fait
diminuer les violences sexistes et
sexuelles c'est bon pour le climat
scolaire en général ça fait c'est le
harcèlement ça n'a que des avantages
alors ensuite on peut dire il vaut mieux
que ce soit dans le cadre familial mais
en réalité l'enseignement et la
sexualité si ça n'est pas à l'école
qu'il assume est-ce que vous croyez que
ce sont toujours les parents qu'ils font
moi je vois aussi
le relais pris malheureusement par
l'industrie pornographique et je me suis
échangé avec trois sénatrices qui m'ont
remis un rapport tout à fait pertinent
sur le sujet il y a quelques mois par
qui au fond madame borque fontains Cohen
et puis rossignol qui ont travaillé sur
sur le sujet et donc il faut aussi se
rendre compte de la situation de nos
élèves et nous avons une mission là qui
est une mission à la fois de
connaissance mais aussi une mission
relative au bien-être de nos élèves qui
a un lien avec la réussite scolaire les
pays qui réussissent très bien dans le
nord de l'Europe ils ont de l'éducation
à la sexualité donc c'est pas apprendre
à lire ou
et ne faire que ça c'est ça combine et
il est question de pédagogie sont
également essentielles en volume
d'heures par exemple de mathématiques
enseignées on est dans la bonne moyenne
européenne donc on peut aussi de manière
je dirais mécanique rajouter des heures
mais ça n'est pas que la nous le faisons
avec leur ennemi de mathématiques mais
ça n'est pas que la seule réponse nous
devons aussi penser aux questions de
pédagogie au type de la manière dont les
mathématiques par exemple sont enseignés
une approche historique très abstraite
dans l'enseignement des mathématiques en
France plus abstraites que dans d'autres
pays il y a des approches qui sont des
approches plus comment dirais-je plus
pratique voire plus ludique il y a un
très bon rapport qui a été remis par
Villani et torosian il y a quelques
années qui le montrent très très bien
donc moi je me permets de souligner le
fait que lorsqu'on parle savoir
fondamentaux on parle aussi pédagogie
type d'enseignement et pas et pas
seulement
l'accroissement c'est pour cela que nous
travaillons justement aux questions de
pédag le plan français le plan
mathématique qui forme des enseignants
dans le premier degré les professeurs
des écoles donnent de très bons
résultats parce que on doit
effectivement travailler la manière dont
le français et les mathématiques sont
enseignés dans le premier degré nous
allons faire de même d'ailleurs avec le
plan maternel pour les professeurs des
écoles qui enseignent en maternelle en
particulier pour l'acquisition du du
vocabulaire un mot sur le le passe
culture madame la député call box je
crois que ça venait de vous on a
effectivement un très bon résultat de
très bons retours en matière
en matière de
passe culture collective avec un après
les années
difficiles de crise sanitaire et autres
il y a une sorte de décollage du passe
culture collectif à partir du mois de
septembre qui était vraiment très
impressionnant bien au-delà de ce qu'on
prévoyait d'ailleurs avec donc 82% des
établissements qui ont activé le Pass
Culture collectif et
2% des élèves qui ont bénéficié du Pass
Culture collectif cette année on va
faire mieux encore l'année prochaine
donc c'est le premier retour retour très
très positif on a encore une difficulté
que vous connaissez sans doute c'est
celle des transports en particulier mais
pas seulement dans les régions rurales
puisque le Pass Culture collectif
ne prend pas en compte le transport
scolaire et donc le coût de location
d'un quart ou le coût de déplacement
vers une activité artistique ou
culturelle peut être à lui seul
prohibitif et bloquer la est bloquer la
l'activité l'activité en cause c'est
quelque chose sur lequel nous
travaillons et le avec le ministère de
la Culture et également avec les
collectivités le bilan est très positif
on n'a pas encore j'ai pas encore de
détails sur le type d'activité mais il y
a un élan là qui est un élan évidemment
extrêmement favorable j'ai bien noté
madame la députée brunira votre point à
propos des décharges et et relative aux
baisses démographiques c'est un point
sur lequel je n'avais pas été
sensibilisé mais je me permettrai de
vous répondre plus plus en détail
là-dessus
une question était posée sur les
disparités je crois que c'était monsieur
le député build sur les disparités entre
bac pro bac technologique et bac général
vous c'est c'est tout à fait
exact nous prévoyons justement dans la
réforme du bac professionnel du travail
en demi-groupe sur les disciplines
fondamentales en particulier le français
et les mathématiques parce que nous
savons que dans les tests de
positionnement de seconde les élèves de
Bac Professionnel ont des résultats en
français en mathématiques qui sont
significativement inférieurs à ceux des
élèves de bac du bac général donc on a
prévu un effort très important du côté
des bacs professionnels qui s'insèrent
dans la réforme générale
des bac pro dont j'ai parlé et dont je
prolonge justement par la la question de
la de madame la députée calvaise sur
l'orientation c'est la découverte des
métiers qui se généralise à partir qui
était expérimenté dans 640 collèges à
cette année qui se généralisée dans les
collèges à partir de la rentrée donc ça
concerne les classes de 5e puis
quatrième et troisième la découverte des
métiers c'est quoi et bien c'est le fait
d'aller visiter une entreprise
ou de découvrir un métier ça peut être
le tribunal de grande instance de la de
la ville s'il s'agit des métiers du
droit enfin il y a énormément de
possibilités parce que les élèves ont
besoin d'avoir un éventail de métier
beaucoup plus grand dans la tête
notamment les métiers industriels qui ne
bénéficie pas toujours d'une image très
favorable
y compris auprès des jeunes filles donc
on a besoin de plus d'élèves dans des
filières qui sont des filières
extrêmement valorisantes on est plus
chez Zola
du côté de beaucoup des entreprises on a
besoin aussi de jeunes filles dans des
filières qui sont encore trop
massivement masculines j'observe aussi
que le stage de troisième qui parfois
aujourd'hui révèle des inégalités
puisque ce sont les filles qui sont les
familles qui sont chargées de trouver le
stage avec les inégalités entre le stage
j'ai entendu l'expression de pousse
grave à une fois et puis des stages
beaucoup plus valorisants et intéressant
là on aura outre le fait que nous devons
nous-mêmes mettre la main à la pâte pour
proposer des stages en lien avec des
associations d'ailleurs pour l'instant
les expériences n'ont pas été si
probantes que ça mais on doit pouvoir
s'améliorer mais surtout le stage de
troisième va intervenir à l'issue de
découverte des métiers de la classe de
5e de 4e et donc les élèves auront déjà
une idée une envie plutôt que de devoir
à la dernière minute à partir de
l'automne de la classe de 3e de voir
trouver un stage et donc je compte
beaucoup aussi sur la participation des
associations et je voulais vous
remercier au passage pour le colloque
tout à fait pertinent que vous aviez
organisé sur le sujet il y a quelques
semaines madame la député meunier vous
m'aviez vous m'avez interrogé sur le
programme phare le fait qu'il y ait
qu'il y a encore des drames vous l'avez
souligné ne doit pas nous amener à
conclure que le programme phare est
inefficace ce que l'on doit en conclure
c'est que le programme PHARE n'est pas
encore complètement appliqué d'une part
parce qu'il a été généralisé aux écoles
et au collège à la rentrée dernière
qu'il est généralisée au lycée à partir
de la rentrée prochaine mais aussi parce
que ce programme dans ces trois
dimensions doit être bien appliquée
dimension de prévention et informations
dimensions de détection et dimensions de
prise en charge dans un certain nombre
de situations on voit que la détection
s'est faite on a on a repéré les
situations de harcèlement ce qui est
bien mais la prise en charge n'a pas
toujours été à la hauteur ou à même été
franchement déficiente on va en voir les
réponses des inspections générales
bientôt
et les rapports qui vont détailler tout
cela donc l'invitation ça n'est pas de
dire on met à la corbeille le programme
farce ça marche pas c'est plutôt on
l'applique aussi bien que possible parce
que lorsqu'il est bien appliqué les
résultats sont là c'est vrai dans les
pays où il a été mis en place pour la
première fois je pense en particulier à
la Finlande qui a été pionnière en la
matière c'est vrai aussi dans les
académies où on l'a expérimenté dans les
six académies on l'a expérimenté à
partir de 2019 par exemple l'Académie de
Bretagne où je me suis penché un peu sur
la situation et on a vu des
améliorations très nettes mais il faut
le mettre en place comme il faut c'est
pour ça que à partir de la rentrée nous
aurons un enseignant référent rémunéré
dans chaque collège qui s'occupera de la
mise en place effective du programme
PHARE donc nous avançons sur le chemin
ce n'est pas moi qui vais vous dire que
tout est parfait mais nous avançons
aussi bien que possible et de manière
extrêmement résolue c'est une des
priorités de la rentrée vous avez parlé
de la question de l'instruction en
famille et la question m'a poser l'année
dernière il y a quatre motifs
d'instruction en famille les trois
premiers ne posent pas beaucoup de
difficultés le quatrième motif est un
motif plus plus contentieux
incontestablement je regardais les
chiffres ce matin on est quel on a
quelque chose comme
90% 89,9% des demandes qui ont été
approuvées donc on est quand même une
situation où les familles obtiennent
satisfaction avec des taux variables
selon les quatre motifs c'est vrai que
le quatrième motif un taux d'approbation
aux alentours de 62% de mémoire donc
c'est moins que les autres que les
autres motifs et on a une question qui a
fait l'objet d'un séminaire national au
début du mois de juin qui était celle de
des réponses inégales selon les
académies avec des académies avec des
réponses non massives et puis des
académies plus plus ouvertes notamment
sur le motif 4 et donc on a on avait
aussi nous à
à réguler les choses pour que
l'éducation nationale puisse offrir une
réponse coordonnée et cohérente et
homogène aux demandes des familles mais
j'aurais été le pourcentage que je
dénais 89,9% des familles ont vu leur
demande d'instruction en famille
approuvées ce qui est quand même on est
loin d'une situation qui qui serait
celle de de suppression ou de quasi
suppression des de l'instruction en
famille on est sur quelque chose comme
60 000 élèves à peu près pour l'année
qui vient de s'écouler à propos des
vacances apprenantes et je ne vous
apprends rien à ce sujet les résultats
sont tout à fait positifs que ce soit
les colos apprenantes ou que ce soit les
stages de réussite il y a en effet un
sujet budgétaire puisque ce système là
avait été mis en place à l'occasion de
la crise
sanitaire du confinement il fallait donc
compenser les fermetures de classe les
les semaines de fermeture de classe par
du temps sur en vacances et donc notre
contenu de la qualité des résultats que
l'on a avec les systèmes de vacances
apprenante nous nous souhaitons et nous
faisons en sorte que ce système soit
prorogé et institutionnalisés en quelque
sorte au-delà de la crise sanitaire ce
qui est occasionne quelques échanges
avec le ministère du Budget le ministère
des comptes publics que je salue au
passage naturellement avec déférence
mais
nous devons faire de telle sorte que
cette ligne budgétaire des vacances
apprenantes soit soit prorogée et
sécurisé
le madame la députée genevère j'ai bien
pris note de ce point sur le lycée de
Moret
et d'une manière plus générale sur les
effets de concurrence qui peuvent avoir
lieu entre CFA et puis lisser
professionnel alors d'une manière
générale la situation est meilleure
qu'il y a quelques années puisque dans
beaucoup de lycées professionnels on
trouve déjà des formations
d'apprentis avec du CFA et du lycée pro
qui partagent des plateaux techniques
similaires notamment des plateaux
techniques très très coûteux dans des
domaines industriels ou autres et des
passages tout à fait intéressants de
jeunes qui passent du CAP au bac pro ou
de jeunes qui passent du bac pro et qui
vont avoir un cap pour compléter une
formation donc on peut tout à fait
penser ces échanges de manière
constructive j'ai eu l'occasion de
visiter des lycées professionnels un peu
partout y compris d'ailleurs pas très
loin de votre région dans le dans le
dans le Jura pour les métiers du bois ou
en
Haute-Savoie pour l'industrie du
décolletage qui
très bien à construire ces tissus entre
petites entreprises et puis lisser
professionnel CFA mais il est possible
en effet je vais me renseigner sur ce
lycée de Moret qu'il y ait localement
des effets de concurrence je l'entends
bien et je vous remercie de de ce point
madame la députée Rani sur les lycées
pourquoi y a-t-il des lycéens non
affectés c'est je me suis j'ai échangé
aussi avec la Défenseur des droits à ce
sujet ce sont pour l'essentiel des
lycéens de lycée pro et dans les lycées
pro il y a une centaine de de
spécialités et donc il y a parfois le
problème qui est celui de lycéen qui
demande des spécialités qui ne sont pas
disponibles dans la région ou dans le
voisinage c'est ça la difficulté pour
l'essentiel les chiffres je ne les ai
pas sous les yeux mais pour l'essentiel
l'hélice les difficultés de
d'affectation elle porte sur les lycées
pro voir les lycées technologiques pour
l'une des 8 filières
technologique
monsieur le député Molac les
on va voir des on n'a pas encore de
retour précis sur le l'inscription dans
les nouvelles missions du pacte et nous
sommes tout à fait optimistes d'ailleurs
on aura des chiffres définitifs à partir
de la mi-septembre lorsque jusqu'à la
rentrée beaucoup de professeurs vont
souscrire à des nouvelles à des
nouvelles missions mais nous sommes tout
à fait optimistes sur notre capacité à
obtenir les pourcentages nécessaires qui
nous permettront la masse critique
nécessaire vous connaissez mon
attachement aux langues régionales j'ai
eu l'occasion de vous le dire et le
redire vous faites allusion peut-être à
la spécialité du bac
de langues régionales
j'attire l'attention sur sur un point
que vous connaissez sans doute c'est que
nous nous sommes tout à fait disposés à
favoriser l'enseignement des langues
régionales mais à hauteur des besoins
identifiés et parfois force est de j'ai
d'ailleurs maintenu le deuxième poste de
capes de Breton l'année dernière ma vie
remercier pour cela et j'en suis très
content mais force est de constater que
les candidats au CAPES de breton ne se
bousculent pas au portillon non plus et
donc la question c'est aussi celle de la
demande et moi je suis prêt à adapter
l'offre mais la demande n'est pas non
plus aussi extraordinaire que cela à
quoi
on en reparlera mais j'ai échangé
effectivement aussi avec le président du
conseil régional à ce sujet y compris
pour des questions de mutation et
également de décharge à propos de
l'enseignement de la langue j'ai pris
note madame la députée kiki des
points que vous des différents éléments
que vous avez indiqués concernant la
Roseraie l'école de la Roseraie à
L'Haÿ-les-Roses et d'autres c'est en
plus ma ville c'est la Fresnes et ma
ville d'enfance donc je connais bien ce
ce petit bout du du Val-de-Marne je
alors il y a vous avez énoncé une série
de de questions je sur la sur la
question des avsh j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire que nous travaillons à une
valorisation des aesh j'ai mentionné les
hausses de salaire la civilisation le
passage vers les 35 heures parce que
leur rémunération n'est en effet pas
suffisante nous avons aussi besoin
d'améliorer la formation 60 heures mais
60 heures qui commencent souvent à
partir du mois de décembre c'est tard
par rapport à la rentrée du mois de
septembre et je
prendrai vous voudrez bien m'écrire pour
me donner les éléments précis sur les
fermetures de classe qui peuvent être
liées à des baisses des effectifs
scolaires nous procédons à des derniers
ajustements au mois d'août il y a trois
phases en ce qui concerne la carte
scolaire février juin et puis août parce
que pendant l'été il y a des
déménagements et des emménagements et
donc les effectifs varient et donc
quelques jours avant la rentrée on
procède à des aménagements et on peut
mettre un poste si le besoin se fait se
fait sentir et enfin Monsieur le Député
des Philippot de
Sarrebourg je
sportif Sarrebourg est en certainement
une ville sportive les 30 minutes
d'activités ont été avec des c'était une
année de mise en route alors il y a
certainement des des inégalités et des
irrégularités la formation des profs on
l'assure par le biais du SCOL et par le
biais de de tout un matériel pédagogique
que nous avons distribué y compris
d'ailleurs du matériel physique avec des
plots etc l'idée c'est dans l'activité
physique c'est deux choses d'une part ce
n'est pas du sport au sens de sport avec
des règles et des et des choses bien
constituées ça ça existe par ailleurs
l'activité physique ça peut être par un
jour pluvieux les élèves restent dans la
classe ils vont faire des exercices
d'assouplissement vous voyez ça peut
être on descend dans le gymnase ou dans
la le préau pour pour mettre trois plots
et pour courir autour des plots avec une
logistique minimale pour que les 30
minutes ne soient pas écrasé par un
dispositif lourd c'est vraiment l'idée
et plutôt que de regrouper sur plusieurs
sur une heure ou deux heures pour avoir
une quelque chose de plus organisé les
spécialistes de en santé publique et
notamment ce professeur de Rennes qui
est l'auteur d'une très grosse étude sur
la détériorisation la détérioration de
de la santé de nos élèves avec des
phénomènes de sédentarité qui font que
leur capacité
cardio-pulmonaires sont moindres
aujourd'hui qu'elle l'était il y a 20
ans dans les proportions d'ailleurs tout
à fait inquiétantes et tout à fait
comment
préoccupante sur les mêmes distances ils
mettent beaucoup plus de temps pour
courir que ouais c'est extrêmement
impressionnant or ce qu'on lit en
consultant cette littérature c'est que
ce qu'il y a de plus efficace c'est tous
les jours et qui vaut mieux faire 30
minutes tous les jours plutôt que deux
fois deux heures
dans deux fois par semaine c'est la
répétition et c'est l'heure en fait une
heure d'exercice par jour c'est ça qui
est recommandé donc avec les 30 minutes
on a déjà la moitié on peut espérer
qu'avec les jeux dans la cour et puis
les allées venus on est l'autre moitié
mais l'idée c'est quand même d'avoir une
heure d'exercice physique par jour mais
cela s'ajoute au sport en tant que tel
et je retiens aussi ce que vous dites à
propos des clubs ça c'est juste mais
c'est ce que nous faisons du côté du
collège puisque là on l'a fait de
manière expérimentale dans quelque chose
comme sans 40 collèges cette année ces
deux heures de sport par semaine non pas
de l'activité physique en lien avec des
clubs et donc là on le on passe à la
vitesse supérieure à partir du mois de
septembre les collégiens auront deux
heures de sport de plus par semaine mais
pas deux heures d'éducation physique et
sportive mais deux heures assurées en
lien avec un club et donc avec eux une
spécialité sportive des environs donc le
on est très attentif à l'articulation
entre club de sport et puis et puis
collège voilà ce que je voulais dire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je crois que vous avez répondu
à toutes les questions de façon
exhaustive donc je vous tenais à vous
remercier pour la qualité des questions
des pas des questions des questions des
questions que vous avez suscité voilà
non mais je remercie pour la qualité des
questions suscitées et pour la qualité
des réponses que vous y avez apportées
et demain matin mes chers collègues nous
continuerons à discuter d'éducation
puisque nous examinerons le rapport de
la mission d'information chargée de
dresser un panorama et un bilan de
l'éducation prioritaire à 10 heures tout
à fait sur ce je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée bonne soirée merci beaucoup